THE FIRST SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR ON
STATE ADMINISTRATION HEARING OF
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN LIKE TO
WELCOME OUR NEW THIS IS A
COMMITTEE THEIR HAIR MISSION IS
AREA MISS CLICKS.
THEY'LL BE HERE SHORTLY I HOPE --
TO REJOIN BUT THE HOUSING AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEES
DISCUSS THE GOVERNOR'S HOUSING
AND HOMELESS PROPOSALS.
TODAY'S HEARINGS INFORMATIONAL
ALLIANCE A CHANCE TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT THESE PROPOSALS.
AND PROVIDE SOME INITIAL
THOUGHTS.
THE GOVERNOR SOME VERY EXCITING
PROPOSALS FOR BOTH HOUSING AND
HOMELESS.
PREVENTION AS SPECIMENS WE'RE
STILL WAITING TO SEE THE DETAILS
AND GET DIRECT FEEDBACK FROM
STAKEHOLDERS.
OBVIOUSLY WE'LL GET ALL OF OUR
QUESTIONS ANSWERED TODAY SO I'M
HOPING WE MOVE THE CONVERSATION
FORWARD.
I'M ALSO HOPING THAT WE DON'T
TAKE FOUR HOURS DO IT LIKE THE
HEARING IN THE SENATE LAST WEEK
[inaudible]
HIT HIM.
BURKE BREVITY IS GREAT.
IN A I SAID THAT THIS IS THIS IS
A MARATHON NOT A SPRINT WE'VE A
LOT OF TIME.
TO GIVE THE INFORMATION THE
MONTHS THE VARIOUS COMMITTEE SO --
NOT A LOT.
I'M UP MISTER TO CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY HOUSING AND MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY TRAVEL GOVERNMENT --
IS THAT YOUR CAREER TECHNICAL
OPENING STATEMENT.
I'M TO MAKE A QUICK THANK YOU
FOR ALL FOR BEING HERE BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT EXTEND MISTER
COOPER'S TIME.
WELL MISTER.
TO BUY IT A FOR OUR OPENING
STATEMENT PREPARED BUT COULD NOT
BACK RIGHT NOW ALSO I JUST WANT
TO THANK ALL OF YOU --
FOR I THINK THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT HEARING I I WANT TO
START BY REALLY THINKING THE
GOVERNOR AND HIS STAFF.
FOR MAKING THE LARGEST GENERAL
FUND --
PROPOSAL --
IN RECENT HISTORY AROUND HOUSING
DURING THIS HOUSING CRISIS AND
OF DOUBLES ALWAYS IN THE DETAILS
LOOK FOR TAKE ANY MORE
INFORMATION BUT CERTAINLY FOR ME
MAKING SURE THAT.
EVERY DOLLARS PUT TO BEST USE
GIVEN THE CRISIS --
IT GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
FACTS AND RESEARCH AND DATA ON
THE GROUND OF WHAT WORKS IS WHAT
I'LL BE INTERESTED IN BUT LOOK
FOR THE CONVERSATION.
MR LAURIA JACK MOCAMA
[inaudible]
MISTER REAVIS.
THANK YOU SIR.
WHAT ONE ITEM NUMBER ISSUE
NUMBER ONE GOVERNOR SHORT TERM
PLANNING AND PRODUCTION GRANTS?
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRS IN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE DANIELLE
BRANDON DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ISSUE ONE IS THE GOVERNOR SHORT
TERM PLANNING AND PRODUCTION
GRANTS THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT.
WHO WILL PROVIDE FUNDING TO
PARTNER WITH AND INCENTIVIZE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO JUMP START
HOUSING PRODUCTION?
THESE RESOURCES ARE INTENDED TO
PROVIDE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
RESOURCES TO REACH NEW SHORT
TERM GOALS BUT TO ALSO PUT THEM
IN A BETTER POSITION TO MEET
LONG TERM RINA GóMEZ. EIGHT
CITY WILL STAB SHORT TERM
STATEWIDE GOALS FOR NEW HOUSING
PRODUCTION ACROSS ALL INCOME
LEVELS AND WILL ALLOCATE THESE
GOALS TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
THESE GOALS WILL INCLUDE ANNUAL
TARGETS OF NEW HOMES STATEWIDE
FOR TWO YEARS AND WE ALLOCATED
TO EACH JURISDICTION IN AN
OBJECTIVE CALCULATION THAT
CONSIDERS FACTORS SUCH.
AS EACH JURISDICTION SHARE OF
THE COUNTIES HOUSEHOLDS JOB
AVAILABILITY AND OVER PAYING LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
JURISDICTIONS ARE ENCOURAGED TO
PLANS MEET THESE TARGETS WHAT IT.
HOWEVER THEY MAY DEEM FIT WHAT
WE ARE STILL WORKING TO FINALIZE
THE TRAILER BILL I AM HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS I CAN AT
THIS TIME.
FOR LL.
BRING YOU LOWER WITH THE LA --
AS MISPRINT AN OUTLINE THERE'S
KIND OF TWO MAIN COMPONENTS OF
THE GOVERNOR SHORT TERM HOUSING
PRODUCTION PROPOSAL THE FIRST IS
TO CREATE THESE NEW SHORT TERM
HOUSING PRODUCTION TARGETS AND
PROVIDE PLANNING.
FUNDS TO CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
PLAN TO MEET TO SET ASIDE A FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR POT FOR
INCENTIVE REWARDS.
WE HAVE CONCERNS ON BOTH OF
THESE PIECES OF OF THE PROPOSAL
FIRST ON THE ON THE PART ABOUT
CREATING SHORT TERM HOUSING
PRODUCTION GOALS --
WE WOULD KNOW THAT THE STATE HAS
HAD A STRATEGY OF OF CREATING
STATE DEFINED HOUSING TARGETS
FOR COMMUNITIES AND ASKING IN
THE PLAN FOR THEM FOR SEVERAL
DECADES.
THROUGH THE HOUSING ELEMENT AND
REASON A HOUSING NEEDS
ALLOCATION ARENA PROCESS --
AN ACADEMIC RESEARCH AND WORK BY
OUR OFFICE HAS GENERALLY FOUND
OF THAT THAT THAT THAT PROCESS
HAS BEEN INEFFECTIVE IN A
STIMULATING HOUSING PRODUCTION.
ON HELPING TO MAKE THIS A
MEANINGFUL CHANGES TO LOCAL
ZONING LAWS THAT FACILITATE A
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT --
BECAUSE OF THAT WE THINK IT
WOULD BE THOSE SO YOUR WOULD BE
BETTER OFF.
NOT FOCUSING ON THE SHORT TERM
GOALS BUT INSTEAD CONTINUING ON
THE WORK IN THE EFFORTS IT'S
BEEN DOING OVER THE PAST COUPLE
YEARS.
AND LOOKING FOR WAYS TO REFORM
AND IMPROVE THE STATE'S EXISTING.
STRUCTURE FOR LONG TERM PLANNING.
ON THE FIVE IN A MILLION DOLLAR
FOR INCENTIVE GRANTS.
OF THE WE'VE WE THINK THAT THIS
WOULD BE A A RISKY BET FROM THE
LEGISLATURE'S PERSPECTIVE THE
STATE HAS TRIED A SIMILAR
APPROACHES IN THE PAST OF
SETTING ASIDE FUNDS.
TO PROVIDE INCENTIVES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO ATTEMPT TO
ENCOURAGE THEM TO TO BUILD
HOUSING --
OUR REVIEW OF THE EVIDENCE
SUGGESTS THAT THOSE PROGRAMS
DIDN'T --
INCREASE --
AND SO THE LEGISLATURE CAN'T BE
CERTAIN WHAT IT WOULD GET BY
SETTING ASIDE THIS FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION.
IT WOULD THEREFORE BE RISKY
COMPARED TO ON ALTERNATIVE OF OF
FOR EXAMPLE JUST ALLOCATING THE
FUNDING FOR DIRECT SUBSIDIES FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CONSTRUCTION.
WITH THAT I'D TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THE QUESTIONS WE CAN MAKE MISTER.
LITERATURE.
GLORIA.
NO I WANTED TO FOR TO MEMBER
HASN'T TOTALLY AGE FIRST --
COUPE I. LOVE THE COMMITTEE WITH
YOU.
ON HOW TO IT SO THAT'S THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE --
FOR SPONSORED LA AS COMMENTS.
I WOULD SAY THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PACKAGE OVERALL TAKES A
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT VARIOUS
FACTORS OF HOUSING INCLUDING
SHORT TERM GOALS LONG TERM GOALS.
AND OTHER ASPECTS SUCH AS YOU
KNOW THE AIR SPACE ISSUE IN THE
C. QUESTION THAT WE'RE WORKING
ON SO I WOULD SAY ONCE THE
TRAILER BILL COMES OUT WOULD BE
PROBABLY MORE --
READY TO ANSWER INMORE DETAIL
SOTHE LONG TERM SOLUTIONS ARE
GONNA BE IN THE TRAILER BILL.
THAT AND CAN'T SPEAK TO THAT
RIGHT NOW I THINK THAT I MEAN
FOR SOME WE GET OFF THE FROM
START IT'S WONDERFUL TO HAVE IT
ACTIVISTS GOVERNOR THE CARES
DEEPLY ABOUT HOUSING I WANT TO
MAKE ANY BONES ABOUT THAT --
AT THE SAME TIME THOUGH I WOULD
IDENTIFY MYSELF WITH SOME OF THE
COMMENTS OF THE LA --
IN TERMS OF THE SIZE OF THE
DOLLAR AMOUNTS THAT ARE HERE ME
FIVE MILLION TO FIFTY MILLION
REAL MONEY --
BUT WE KNOW IN TERMS OF SIZE AND
SCOPE OF THIS PROBLEM --
YOU KNOW WE DID FIVE MILLION
LAST YEAR RIGHT THE CRISIS IS
NOT GOING. TO MAKE MY
CONSTITUENTS HAPPY --
AND SO THE THE LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS I THINK I'M MOST
MEANINGFUL IT'S DIFFICULT TO
APPROVE.
A THREE QUARTERS OF A BILLION
DOLLARS WITHOUT KNOWING WHAT THE
LONG TERM SOLUTIONS MAY BE ON
THAT COULD BE A BRIDGE TO LONG
TERM SOLUTIONS I THINK THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE ALLUDING TO BUT NOT
KNOWING WHAT THOSE ARE --
IT'S CONCERNING TO ME AS A
LEGISLATOR.
JUST.
FOLLOWING UP Là MILESTONES WITH
US ACTUALLY CURRENT.
TWENTY NINETEEN I DON'T HAVE
THAT TIME LINE RIGHT WE DON'T
HAVE THAT TIME LINE PIN DOWN YET.
MISTER LOOK I'M SORRY MR.
TO MISTER GORE THANK GOD GOT
MUCH OF THE JUST A WHERE I WAS
GOING DALY OWES --
RESPONSE TO THESE --
TO THIS PROPOSAL WAS WAS WAS
PRETTY STARK --
AND I THINK MANY OF US CERTAINLY
WANT LOCALS --
TO AS I THINK. TO HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO DO THE
PLANNING THEY NEED TO DO.
AND FRANKLY TO AFTER THIS YEAR
NO LONGER HAVE THE EXCUSES THAT
WE HAVEHEARD FROM THEM FOR MANY
YEARS -- SO
YOU DON'T HAVE ANSWERS ON A TWO
A PORTION TO CITIES AND COUNTIES
SURE AND WE DO ANTICIPATE THAT
THE PLANNING FINDINGS WILL BE
PROVIDED BOTH DIRECTLY TO
JURISDICTIONS AS WELL AS TO ON A
REGIONAL BASIS. TO ENCOURAGE
ABOUT COLLABORATION --
AND THAT'S ABOUT AS MUCH DETAIL
AS I HAVE AT THIS TIME SO AT
THIS POINT BASED ON POPULATION
SIZE SIZE THE HOUSING NEED OTHER
FACTORS ANY OTHER FACTORS HERE
WHERE OF COURSE OF FINALIZING
THOSE METRICS OKAY AND THEN
COULD YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY SENSE
OF WHAT KIND OF MILESTONES.
WILL PASS YOU FROM.
THE TO UNDER FIFTY TO THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION.
STILL WORKING ON THOSE AS WELL
AND SOME OF THE ITEMS THAT ARE
INCLUDED ARE I'M A HEARING TO
SUM UP AS STANDARD STATE LAWS
SUCH AS I HAVEN'T.
THE COMPLETED AND CERTIFIED
HOUSING ELEMENT PRODUCTION
ENTITLEMENTS AND PROCESS FIX
FEES WHAT I CAN SEE IS WHAT WE
INTEND THAT THE BASIS OF THE A
SENTENCE WILL BE BASED ON WHAT
THE LOCALS CAN DO AND NOT.
ISSUES OUTSIDE OF THEIR CONTROL.
OKAY WHAT WHAT'S YOUR SENSE OF
WHEN WE COULD EXPECT MORE
DETAILS ON THIS I AM HESITANT TO
SPEAK TO EXACT TIME I'M HOPING
VERY SOON OKAY THANKS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
YEAH -- I TO
APPRECIATE ALEJO'S REPORT --
SOMETIMES I FEEL LIKE WE JUST
THROW MONEY AT THINGS AND NOT
REALLY THINK ABOUT THE ENTIRE.
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES --
BUT I'M ANXIOUS TO FIND OUT THE
WHAT ELSE IS WHAT KIND OF TIME
FRAME AS YOU AND I OBVIOUSLY
DON'T HAVE THE ANSWERS THEY BUT
TIME FRIENDS ARE IMPORTANT TO ME
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE DRAFT REPORT PERIODICALLY
THOSE OF THE THINGS I WOULD BE
LOOKING FOR TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
MOVE THESE KINDS OF THINGS --
FOR AND I ALWAYS AM CONCERNED
THAT WE MAKE SURE THAT ARE SMALL
CITIES A REAL COMMUNITIES GET
THEIR THEIR FAIR SHARE OF THE
FUNDING THAT MAY GO OUT IN THE
FUTURE.
IF THE QUESTIONS WERE COMMITTEE.
THIS TOTALING UP LET PUBLIC
COMMENT.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK ON THE SIDE
OF MISTER CHAIR MADAM CHAIR
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TIM SHOT ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA RAPID TRANSIT DISTRICT --
BOARD HAS ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY ACRES OF DEVELOP A LAND
THAT THEY OWN.
AND WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF DO
YOU SING A VERY AMBITIOUS GOAL
OF TWENTY THOUSAND UNITS ON THAT
PROPERTY WAS SEVEN THOUSAND OF
THEM BEING AFFORDABLE.
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
THE B. TWENTY NINE TWENTY THREE
GOVERNOR SIGNED IT THANK YOU
SIMPLY MEMBER --
TO WHICH GRANTS PART THE
AUTHORITY TO REZONE ON THEIR
LAND.
THE END --
BART IS --
UNDERTAKING THAT RESPONSIBILITY
NOW WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS --
IT IT IS A CHALLENGE WE HAVE ONE
PLANNER AND WE WOULD SUGGEST
THAT IF IN FACT YOU GO FORWARD
WITH THE SHORT TERM PLANNING
GRANTS.
THAT YOU INCLUDE APPROPRIATE
ELIGIBLE TRANSIT THAT IS IN FACT
DEVELOPING HOUSING ON THEIR OWN
HANDS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON BILL HIGGINS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
COUNCILS OF GOVERNMENTS AND WE
REPRESENT THE TWENTY AM P. R.
EIGHTEEN NPOS AN THE STATE REP
REQUIRED THE THAT DO THE SYSTEM
WILL COMMUNITY STRATEGY AND THE
TWENTY COGS IN THE STATE THE DO
RENA DISTRIBUTION.
SO MY FIRST POINT ON THE RENEWED.
WE HAVE YET TO FUND THE RENO
DISTRIBUTION AND WE'VE ADDED.
NEW REQUIREMENTS GOOD
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO FAIR
HOUSING BUT IF WE WANT IT DONE
RIGHT WE NEED TO FIGURE THAT OUT
IN THIS BUDGET PROCESS.
THE SECOND PART IS THAT WERE
HAPPY TO PLAY A ROLE IN WHATEVER
WAY WE CAN IN HELPING LOCATE
THIS PLANNING MONEY IN THE AREAS
THAT ARE CONSISTENT WITH OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS OBLIGATIONS.
BECAUSE WHERE WE PUT THIS
HOUSING MATTERS.
IF WE STILL WANT TO ACHIEVE OUR
CLIMATE GOALS AND THIS IS A
DIFFICULT BALANCE BECAUSE WERE
LOOKING TO ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE
ARE TRANSPORTATION AND OUR
HOUSING GOALS ALL AT ONCE.
SO -- WE
LOOK FORWARD --
TO WORKING WITH THAT AND AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN EMPHASIZE
AND PRIORITIZE AREAS.
AND LOCATIONS THAT HELP ME AT
ALL THREE GOALS WE THINK THAT
WOULD BE THE BEST INVESTMENT FOR
THE MONTH FOR THE FUNDS AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
EVERYBODY ON THIS ISSUE THANKS
THANK YOU.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES --
WE ALSO LIKE THE COMMITTEE'S
LOOK FORWARD TO REVIEWING MORE
DETAILS ABOUT THESE PROPOSALS
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS TO
BE EXCITED ABOUT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL BUT I'M WE
DO AGREE WITH SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THE COMMITTEE IS
HIGHLIGHTED --
WE STRONGLY SUPPORTED SB TO
INCLUDING THE ALLOCATION OF THE
FIRST YEAR FUNDING FOR UPDATING
PLANS AND SO WE THINK ADDITIONAL
PLANNING MONEY IS IS LIKELY
HELPFUL --
ON THE SIDE OF THE FIVE AND AN
INCENTIVE PAYMENTS I THINK IN
COUNTY WORLD ESPECIALLY WHERE
FOR FOLKS FACED A LOT OF
INFRASTRUCTURE LIMITATIONS WERE
NOT NECESSARILY THE HOTTEST
MARKETS FOR NEW DEVELOPMENT.
WE KIND OF THINK THERE'S A STEP
MISSING BETWEEN PLANNING AND
THEN HOUSING PRODUCTION ACTUALLY
HAPPENING SO SOMETHING THAT WE'D
LIKE TO DISCUSS WITH THE
COMMITTEE AS THE BUDGET PROCESS
ADVANCES.
IS THE NEED FOR REALLY
IMPLEMENTATION MONEY FOR THE
PLANS THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED SO
WE CAN PLAN FOR HOUSING BUT IF
THE HARD COSTS.
ARE TOO HIGH IF THE MARKET ISN'T
THERE THE PRIVATE SECTOR ISN'T
GOING TO COME IN AND BUILD IT
AND SO.
AS IT RELATES TO UNINCORPORATED
AREAS WE REALLY WANT TO BE
MINDFUL OF THAT GAP AND IF
THERE'S A WAY TO BRING RESOURCES
TO MAKE PROJECTS PENCIL THAT
OTHERWISE WOULDN'T HAPPEN.
BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
COMMITTEE AS THE CONVERSATION
ADVANCES.
THANK YOU.
JEFF TURNER GEAR AN APPLICANT --
BERRIES ORGANIZATIONS KERA --
SHE WE SAY DOGFIGHT EQUITY.
MY CONCERN IS ACCESSIBILITY MY
CONCERN HERE IS IS ARTICLE
THIRTY FOUR ASSISTING YOU IN
GETTING NON PROFITS.
BECAUSE AS OF TWO YEARS AGO YOU
TRIED TO GETTING DOLLARS IN HERE
AND HOW MANY OF THOSE DOLLARS
HAVE YET MANAGE TO HIT.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO YES AT THE
SAME TIME THAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT
SHORT TERM WHERE THOSE FUNDS GET
DIRECTED AT THE END OF KNOWLEDGE
IN THE FACT THAT THE ON THE
CRISIS.
IN BEYOND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO FOR DEVELOPERS.
IS MAKE COMMUNITY LAND TRUST THE
TO GET BUILDINGS GOING NOW.
THANK YOU FOR COMMENTS.
GOOD LOCAL PUBLIC COMMENT REMOVE
ON UNDER.
TO THE GOVERNOR'S LONG TERM
STATEWIDE HOUSING PRODUCTION
STRATEGY.
IS THE PRIORITY OF THE
ADMINISTRATION TO REVAMP THE
CURRENT REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT PROCESS THE RENO
PROCESS WHICH DETERMINES THE
AMOUNT AND TYPE OF HOUSING
REGIONS AND LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
MUST PRODUCE TO MEET THEIR NEEDS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT IN
CONJUNCTION WITH OTHER STATE
OFFICES AND WHAT STAKEHOLDER
PARTICIPATION WILL DEVELOP NEW
RINA PROCESS THE METHODOLOGY
THAT ADDRESSES CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING SHORTAGE.
THE REVAMPED PROCESS WAS
STRONGLY ENCOURAGED
JURISDICTIONS TO CONTRIBUTE
THEIR FAIR SHARE OF HOUSING BY
LINKING TRANSPORTATION.
AND OTHER NON HOUSING FUNDING TO
HOUSING PRODUCTION WHERE YOU'RE
STILL WORKING THROUGH THE
DETAILS WE ANTICIPATE THESE LONG
TERM RINA GOALS WOULD NOT BEGIN
FOR AT LEAST A FEW YEARS TO GIVE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TIME. TO BE
COMPLIANT WITH HOUSING LAW TO
IMPLEMENT CHANGES AND MAKING
PROGRESS TOWARDS HOUSING GOALS
BEFORE SUCH FUNDS ARE WITHHELD.
AND I CAN ANSWER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME AGAIN.
L. L..
WE AGREE WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
THAT --
CONTINUE TO LOOK FOR WAYS TO
IMPROVE --
THE STATE'S ARENA PROCESS IS
WORTHWHILE OF THE LEGISLATURE'S
TAKEN SEVERAL OPTIONS ACTIONS IN
THIS AREA IN RECENT YEARS --
THAT BEING SAID WE THINK THAT
THERE ARE REMAIN ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE THE
PROCESS --
AND WE OUTLINED SOME SUGGESTIONS
AND ARE A RECENT REPORT WHICH
YOU CAN FIND ON OUR WEBSITE --
HOPEFULLY ALL OF YOUR OFFICES OF
RECEIVE COPIES OF A JUST QUICKLY
SUMMARIZE SOME OF THE IDEAS IN
THERE -- WE
SUGGEST BETTER IN COURT INTO THE
CALCULATION OF COMMUNITIES
HOUSING GOALS LENGTHENING THE
PLANNING HORIZON FROM EIGHT
YEARS OR SOMETHING LONGER
PERHAPS TWENTY YEARS --
FURTHER ENHANCING STATE
OVERSIGHT AND ENFORCEMENT OF
HOUSING ELEMENTS PRINTING LOCAL
IN USE RULES WORK COMMUNITIES
ARE NOT FAITHFULLY PARTICIPATING
IN THE HOUSING ELEMENT PROCESS.
AND ALTERING THE ALLOCATION OF
LOCAL TAXES --
TO BETTER INCENTIVIZE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO PLAN FOR AND
IMPROVE HOUSING --
WITH THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO GET
INTO ANY OF THE DETAILS ON THOSE --
SHOULD THE COMMITTEE WISH.
TO SEARCH YOU.
OUGHT TO THE TO FIND OUT SO
DIRECTIONALLY VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE IDEA OF RE HOLLY RINA AND
WANT TO THANK OUR COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM AND OTHERS
WHO HAVE REALLY.
MOVE THIS CONVERSATION FORD --
TWO QUESTIONS ONE JUST WANT TO
GET A SENSE OF WHEN TO EXPECT
STAKEHOLDER CONVERSATIONS TO
HAPPEN AROUND RENO WHAT'S YOUR
TIME FRAME FOR THAT.
AND THEN THE OTHER BIG IDEA THAT
YOU HAVE IN THE SECTION IS RUN
HOW YOU TIE TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING --
TO HOUSING PRODUCTION AND YOU
HAVE A SENSE OF WHAT TYPE OF
TRANSPORTATION FUNDS ARE TALKING
ABOUT WHAT OTHER TYPES OF
FUNDING ARE YOU LOOKING AT HOW
DOES THAT GET TIED.
WHAT'S TIME FROM FOR WHEN THAT
PROPOSAL'S GONNA COME BECAUSE
THAT'S GOING TO THROUGH THE
DETAILS ON THE STATE WHEN WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO INCORPORATE
THE STAKEHOLDERS DISCUSSIONS --
SET THE BEST I CAN OFFER YOU ON
THAT RESPONSE BUT WITH REGARD TO
THE TRANSPORTATION FUNDS WE ARE
CONSIDERING LINKING THE LOCAL
STREETS AND ROADS FUNDS UNDER SB.
ONE AS WELL AS OTHER
TRANSPORTATION IN ON HOUSING
FUNDS WHICH WE ARE STILL LOOKING
INTO IT THIS TIME.
AND LOCAL AGENCIES MAN ENOUGH
THAT THEY WILL HAVE TIME TO WORK
TOWARDS MEETING THEIR GOALS
BEFORE THESE THAT.
FUNDING IS WITH HEALTH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
OKAY.
I'M GOING OPEN UP PUBLIC COMMENT
THIS TIME A WHEN WE SPEAK ON
THIS ITEM.
DESPITE WHAT COMMON.
SURE.
I'M TAKEN BACK RIGHT NOW.
HOME BECAUSE OF GOING AFTER
USING SB ONE FUNDING.
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT I THINK
THEY SHOULD BE ON THE TABLE I'M
JUST THROWING IT OUT THERE RIGHT
NOW.
A WE WORK TOO HARD ON THAT AND
TO ALL OF A SUDDEN HAVE THAT
THROUGH USED AS A POTENTIAL.
IS DISTURBING TO ME SO I'M
HOPING WE CAN WORK THINGS OUT
AND FIND A DIFFERENT WAY BUT
THAT ONE IS.
AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED AS WE
SIT HERE OFF LIMITS ON THEIR
COMMENTS MADE THE VOTERS AND
PROMISES MADE AND THAT WAS A
VERY HEAVY LIFT LAST YEAR.
AND THE VOTERS TO A CERTAIN
EXPECTATION OF THOSE FUNDS BE
USED FOR WAS PROMISED.
IN OUT OF CHANGE THAT MID STREAM
ROUGH ALLOW FOLKS WRONG.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS --
KICK POLEMIC CULTURE RISK
PRISCILLA --
SO THAT MIGHT HAVE JUST BEEN
KIND OF FLUID IN THERE WHERE I
DIDN'T GET THE GRAVITY OF THAT.
SO CAN YOU CLARIFY WHAT YOU WERE
SAYING WITH THE S. B. ONE FUNDS
AND HOUSING AND TRANSPORTATION.
TRANSPORTATION.
SURE AND WE ARE CONSIDERING
LINKING THE LOCAL STREETS AND
ROAD FUNDS UNDER SB ONE AS WELL
AS OTHER TRANSPORTATION ON
HOUSING DOLLARS WHICH WE HAVE
NOT YET IDENTIFIED. TO MEETING
THOSE HOUSING PRODUCTION GOALS.
SO YOU'RE SAYING THAT IF THERE'S
A HOUSING PROJECT TO THAT IS.
CLOSE TO TRANSPORTATION LINES
THEN THERE COULD BE MONEY TAKEN
FROM SB ONE FOR THAT PROJECT.
IS A WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
WE'RE STILL WORKING THROUGH THE
MECHANICS I DON'T KNOW THAT IT --
HOW SPECIFIC IT IS --
I HAVE MY COLLEAGUE HERE ON THE
REPRESENTS TRANSPORTATION IF HE
HAS ANYTHING BAD.
PELOSI WELLS --
FROM DEPARTMENT FINANCE --
THERE'S NOT THAT WE WOULDN'T
LINK ANY OF THE S. ALL THE SP
ONE FUNDING WOULD BE USED FOR
THE PURPOSES THAT IS ALREADY
STATUTORILY REQUIRED TO BE USED
SO.
THE LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS
FUNDING WOULD STILL BE USED FOR
THE SAME LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS
PROGRAMS THAT THEY HAVE NOW.
BUT THE ALLOCATION OF THOSE
FUNDS WOULD BE --
WOULD THERE WOULD BE YOU KNOW
THERE'S KERN --
STATUTORY FORMULAS FOR ALL THOSE
FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED AND WE JUST
PROPOSED TO LOOK AT IN ADDITION
TO THOSE TOUCH WHAT FUNDS
SOMETHING THAT IS LINKED TO THE
PRODUCTION OF HOUSING UNITS BUT
FUNDS THEMSELVES WOULD STILL
JUST BE FOR THE LOCAL STREETS
AND ROADS PROCOPE.
KILLING ME JUST ASK ONE MORE
CLARIFICATION.
JUST BECAUSE I WANNA MAKE SURE
I'M UNDERSTANDING THE THOUGHT
PROCESS SO.
THE THE MONEY THAT'S ALREADY
ALLOCATED TO INDIVIDUAL CITIES
BY FOUR FORMULA WOULD CONTINUE
TO BE --
GIVEN TO EACH CITY AS ALREADY
THAT IT'S DESIGNED TO DO FOR
MAJOR PROJECTS LIKE FREEWAYS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT MONEY WOULD
GO TO WHERE IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
ALLOCATED.
BUT THIS WOULD BE ANOTHER PART
OF A POT OF MONEY IF YOU WANT TO
SAY THAT COULD BE GIVEN IF
CITIES ARE.
ACTUALLY MOVING TOWARDS
TRANSPORTATION SLASH HOUSING.
WILL THERE IS STILL A LOT OF
THAT YOU KNOW DELIBERATION BACK
AND FORTH OF ZACHARY HOW TO
APPLY BUT THE IDEA IS THAT.
CITIES THAT HAVE YOU KNOW THAT
WHATEVER HOWEVER THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS
THAT IS DETERMINED OR OTHER
PROGRAMS I THERE'S LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS OR SEVERAL
DIFFERENT SB ONE POTS.
THAT THOSE FUNDS WOULD STILL BE
USED FOR THE SAME HIGH --
PROJECTS IN THE IN THE CASE
ILLUSTRATES ROADS NOT HIGHWAY
PROJECTS THAT WOULD BE.
ESSENTIALLY --
IN A LOCAL PROJECTS OF STREET
REPAIR THAT'S THE THING BUT THE
THE FACTORS BY WHICH THE AMOUNT
THAT IS --
CALCULATED OR THE THE FACTORS
THAT CURRENT YOU KNOW THEY'RE
THE SCO STILL THE CURRENTLY
PROCESSES.
OF LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS
FUNDING AND A HALF AND LOCALS
MEET CERTAIN CRITERIA IN ORDER
TO RECEIVE THOSE FUNDS.
AND SO --
THERE IS DELIBERATIONS ON HOW WE
CAN INCLUDE REACHING --
LONG TERM OR MID TERM --
HOUSING GOALS AS PART OF THE US
FOR TERROR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BOERNER HORVATH THANK YOU --
I JUST WANT TO RECAP I'M NEW SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT RENO
NUMBERS ARE PLANNING GOALS.
AND YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
REACHING THE PRODUCTION UNITS OF
THOSE RECYCLES.
AND YOU'RE TRYING SB ONE THE
MONEY TO THE PRODUCTION WERE
CITIES ARE ONLY ACCOUNTABLE TO
THE PLANNING FOR IT AND SO
THERE'S A THERE'S A FLAW I THINK
AND NOT LOGIC.
BECAUSE I I CAN UNDERSTAND
HOLDING BACK SB ONE MONEY IF
THEY'RE NOT COMPLIANT WITH HDD I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT THE
PRODUCTION GOALS AS ALSO
PARTIALLY ON THE PRIVATE MARKET.
AND SO CITIES CANNOT BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT MECHANISM
THE PRIVATE MARKET.
AND IT YOU YOU CORRECT AND WE WE
ARE VERY YOU KNOW MUCH
DIFFERENCE TO THAT THE I THINK
THERE ARE GOALS THERE ARE
PLANNING GOALS THERE ARE.
THERE ARE.
MULTIPLE DIFFERENT GOALS THAT
COULD BE LOOKED AND AND
DETERMINED --
WHETHER YOU KNOW GOOD FAITH
PROGRESS IS BEING MADE TOWARDS
HOUSING GOALS SO I THINK THAT
THAT'S ALL PART OF THE
LIBERATION THAT'S HAPPENING
BEFORE.
WE DECIDE ON ANY YOU KNOW FINAL
NUMBERS ARE FINAL GOALS FOR WHAT
WHAT IS GOING TO BE TALLIED TO
DETERMINE YOU KNOW COMPLIANCE.
I WOULD JUST ADD THAT WE ARE
AWARE THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN
MEASURES AND ONLY CERTAIN
MEASURES THAT LOCALS CAN DO TO
AND SENT IT TO GET PRODUCTION.
MOVING AND SO WE ARE TRYING TO
FOCUS ON WHAT IS IN THE CONTROL
OF THE CITY SOME NOTE AND I'LL
MAKE SURE THAT MAY I GO BACK AND
DOUBLE CHECK THE FACTS OF MY
STATEMENT.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT IN
A LOT OF CITIES WHERE HOUSING IS
MORE DIFFICULT ONE OF THE
BIGGEST OBSTACLES TO HOUSING IS
TRAFFIC CONGESTION.
SO IF WE'RE TAKING AWAY THE SP
ONE MONIES FOR LOCAL ROADS WERE
BASICALLY TAKING AWAY CITIES
ABILITY TO SOLVE CRAP TRAFFIC
CONGESTION TO ACTUALLY CREATE
THAT HOUSING THAT'S POSSIBLE SO
LET'S BE VERY CAREFUL IN HOW WE
APPROACH THIS.
AND WHAT'S THE ROLE OF THE CITY
WHAT'S THE ROLE OF THE PRIVATE
MARKET THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA --
DC TENSIONER OF WHICH BUT THAT'S
OKAY WERE REALLY THE PROCESS
YOU'RE COLLECTING FEEDBACK AND I
THINK IT'S GOOD LISTEN THE NEED
TO BE SOME CARROTS AND STICKS IN
THIS ARRANGEMENT WE CAN'T
REPRESENTED EVERY CITIES A GOOD
ACTOR WE KNOW SOME OF THEM
AREN'T APPRECIATE THE IDEA OF
TRYING TO INCENTIVIZE.
CITIES TO TO DO THE RIGHT THING --
I DO HAVE SOME RESERVATIONS
ABOUT SB ONE FUNDS --
GIVEN THE THE INVOLVEMENT OF THE
VOTERS ON THIS AND AND STAYING.
TRUE TO WHAT WAS REPRESENTED TO
THEM ANYWHERE ELSE TO NOT BE
MISAPPROPRIATED IS JUST A
CERTAIN RESTRICTIONS WHEN GET IT.
THAT MAY BE DIFFICULT I WOULD
ASK ARE YOU EXPANDING THE POTS
OF FUNDS BEYOND TRANSPORTATION
FUNDS --
SPOKE WITH INCENTIVE GRANTS --
THAT IT KEPT TRADE FUNDS I MEAN
ARE THERE OTHER FUNDING SOURCES
THAT YOU'RE CONSIDERING AS
INCENTIVES --
TO BE WITHHELD --
IF JURISDICTIONS ARE DOING THEIR
FAIR SHARE ON HOUSING.
RIGHT NOW I BELIEVE WE'RE
LOOKING AT JUST.
ALL OF THE FUNDING SOURCES
AVAILABLE WHAT CAN BE TIGHTS
WERE STILL VERY IN THE
PRELIMINARY STAGES RIGHT NOW
WE'VE IDENTIFIED SOME SB ONE
FUNDS --
THAT'S ALL WE HAVE BLATANT BY
OUR ENCOURAGED TO LOOK BEYOND
THAT AND I THINK THERE'S A LOT
OF CARE IT'S AT THE STATE
PROVIDES TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS --
AND I THINK THE ONES THAT ARE AT
ENHANCING OR YOU KNOW OFTEN
THESE FUNDS ARE USED TO HELP
OFFSET THE THE IMPACTS OF
DIVIDENDS DEVELOPMENT --
YOU KNOW COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DOING THAT SHOULD PROBABLY
SHOULD HAVE TO COMPETE AGAINST
COMMUNITIES ARE NOT A SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY CAN PUT TOGETHER A
CANCER PROPOSAL IF YOU CATCH MY
DRIFT AND MAYBE THAT SIMPLISTIC
OR MAY NOT EVEN FACTUAL BUT I
I'D LIKE YOU LOOK IN THAT
DIRECTION TO BE.
INCLUSIVE OF THAT --
GIVEN THE POLITICAL [inaudible]
YOUR QUESTIONS.
OKAY WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT.
A GOOD AFTERNOON LUIS MONTANA
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA BE.
FIGURE OUT THIS MIKE --
WE WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL --
ULTIMATELY HAVE --
SOME SOME SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
FEEDBACK THOUGH --
ON THE ISSUE OF OF RENO TWO
POINT NOW WE'RE A LITTLE BIT FOR
A LITTLE BIT SKEPTICAL.
THAT THAT'LL BE A SUCCESSFUL
PROCESS ONE OF THE THE MAIN
PROBLEMS WITH TRYING
TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS. TO RENEW
GOALS IS THAT THERE ARE SEVERAL
CITIES ABOUT.
TWENTY FIVE THAT ACTUALLY DO
MEET ALL CATEGORIES OF THEIR
VEHICLES THAT PROBABLY WOULD NOT.
IN MOST PEOPLE'S MINDS SATISFY
THAT THE SENSE THAT THEY'RE
THEY'RE DOING THE RIGHT THING ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PRODUCTION.
AND THAT'S JUST AN INHERENT FLAW
OF ANYWAY THE STATE'S GOING TO
ANY TOOL THE STATE'S GONNA HAVE.
TO ANALYZE PRODUCTION BUT WE
WOULDN'T WANT FOR BILL WHICH IS
AFFIRMATIVELY DOING THE RIGHT
THING BUT NOT MEETING.
THEIR PMR RINA CATEGORIES TO BE
PUNISHED FOR THAT --
WHILE OTHER CITIES THAT ARE
MEETING THEIR PMR CATEGORIES
BECAUSE THEY'RE PMR CATEGORY IS --
ZERO GET OFF SCOT FREE THAT THAT
THE DIFFICULTY THAT WILL HAVE TO
APPROACH.
WE WOULD ALSO KIND OF HAVE
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT FEEDBACK ON
THE ON THE HOUSING DOLLARS
TRYING TO HOUSING DOLLARS TO
HOUSING GOALS.
IN IN BIG PART BECAUSE WE WANT
TO FOCUS AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
THOSE IN THOSE CITIES THAT HAVE
ACCESS TO THE HIGHEST
OPPORTUNITY TO THE BEST SCHOOLS
THE BEST NEIGHBORHOODS THE BEST
AIR QUALITY.
AND SO TYING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DOLLARS --
TO MEETING STATE HOUSING GOALS
COULD ACTUALLY CREATE THE WRONG
INCENTIVE FOR CITIES THAT DON'T
WANT AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THEIR
COMMUNITY --
ENCOURAGING THEM ACTUALLY TO BE
WORSE ON THEIR HOUSING GOALS --
BECAUSE THEY WOULDN'T GET THAT
HOUSE AND ALSO I THINK THERE'S
NEW WANTS THEIR THAT THE
ASSEMBLY IS IT IS IT WOULD IS
RIGHT TO BE CONSIDERING THERE
TOO PROPOSALS --
AND THE ASSEMBLY NOW THAT I
THINK ARE ARE BOB VERY WORTH
CONSIDERING --
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBERS DALY AND
AND CARTY --
IT WOULDN'T MOST OF THAT MOST OF
THESE PROPOSALS ONE ACTUALLY
TAKE AWAY THE MONEY FROM THE
CITY'S I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT DISTINCTION.
IT WOULD PUT A LOT OF THE MONEY
IN ESCROW AND THEN THE CITY
WOULD GET IT BACK ONCE.
THE REQUIREMENT WAS SATISFIED --
ONCE IT MET SOME OBJECTIVE
STANDARD THAT THE STATE SET FOR
IT AND SO THAT MONEY WOULD BE
USED FOR THE PURPOSES.
UNDER THAT SITUATION THAT THE
VOTERS APPROVED ITS USE.
OF FORCE SO I YOU KNOW I THINK
THERE'S SOME I THINK THERE'S
SOME THERE'S SOME NEW ONES HERE
APPRECIATE ALL THE
THOUGHTFULNESS FROM ALL THAT.
THE MEMBERS THE ASSEMBLY WHO ARE
WORKING ON THIS AND AND PROPOSAL
IN GENERAL BUT YOU KNOW IT
KNOWLEDGE IN THAT THERE'S A
PROCESS STILL HAPPEN THANKS.
THANK YOU.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES --
APPRECIATE THE PERSPECTIVE FROM
THE COMMITTEE ABOUT SOME OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUES HERE WITH
THIS CONCEPT OF USING.
THE REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ALLOCATION AS SORT OF A DE FACTO
PRODUCTION QUOTA --
WE DEFINITELY APPRECIATE THE
COMMITMENT BY THE ADMINISTRATION
THAT THEY DO NOT INTEND TO HOLD
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNTABLE
FOR FACTORS THAT ARE BEYOND
THEIR CONTROL.
AND I THINK BEFORE WE TALK ABOUT
USING OUR EXISTING RENO GOALS OR
SOME FUTURE LONG TERM HOUSING
PRODUCTION GOAL.
AS A STANDARD AGAINST WHICH
FUNDING IS GOING TO BE ALLOCATED
WE HAVE TO BE VERY.
COGNIZANT OF THE DIFFERENT TYPES
OF MARKETS THAT EXIST IN THE
STATE THE FACT IS THE LA --
NOTED THAT THE EXISTING GOALS
ARE NOT NECESSARILY ALLOCATED
BASED ON MARKET DEMAND BUT BY
DEMOGRAPHIC FACTORS BASICALLY
WHERE THERE ARE PEOPLE NOW WE
WILL HAVE MORE --
ALLOCATIONS IN THE FUTURE AND WE
HAVE TO BE REALLY SERIOUS ABOUT
THE FACT THAT THE LA --
AND OTHERS HAVE IDENTIFIED THAT
WE PLAN FOR MUCH MORE BELOW
MARKET RATE HOUSING IN OUR LAND
USE PLANS THEN THE STATE FEDERAL
OR LOCAL GOVERNMENT WILL
REALISTICALLY FIND AND SO UNLESS
WE'RE GOING TO DRASTICALLY
REDUCE.
OUR PLANNING GOALS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE'RE REALLY
JUST SETTING UP JURISDICTIONS TO
FAIL IF WE'RE GOING TO USE THAT
AS THE YARDSTICK AGAINST WHICH
THEIR TRANSPORTATION FUNDING IS
MEASURE --
SO AGAIN APPRECIATE THE
COMMITMENT BY THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR A STAKEHOLDER PROCESS AND
REALLY ASK RECOGNITION THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF FACTORS IN
HOUSING PRODUCTION THAT ARE NOT
UNDER THE CONTROL BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
AND CITY COUNCILS AND WE'LL LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING.
CHAPTER TO GEAR AGAIN ADVOCATE --
THESE [inaudible] TEN YEARS.
YOU'RE NEEDING TO FOCUS A LOT
LONGER PERIOD AND THE CONCEPT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BEING BUILT
FOR FORTY YEARS.
LIKE WISE SEEMS TO ME THAT TO IN
THESE CONSIDERATIONS I THINK THE
LONG TERM IS SOMETHING THAT YOU
NEED.
TO BASICALLY. TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AS A MARKETING TOOL AND AGAIN
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT RIGHT NOW --
THAT FOR THE NEXT DECADE YOU ARE
GOING TO MEET THE INCREDIBLE
SHORTAGE NEEDS THAT HAVE TAKEN
MORE THAN TWO DECADES. TO CREATE
THE SITUATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
BUT THEN.
I'M BILL HIGGINS WITH CAL CALLED
AGAIN AND I'M MINDFUL OF THE
FOUR O'CLOCK OR FOUR HOURS I'LL
KEEP IT SHORT.
OF YOU YOU'RE WELCOME --
I JUST WANTED TO SAY ABOUT THE
SHORT TERM AND THE LONG TERM
RINA GOAL --
RIGHT NOW WHAT WE'RE GOING
THROUGH AND ABOUT TO GET THE
FIRST ROUND OF RINA NUMBERS FOR
THE NEXT ROUND OF PLANNING
CYCLES.
AND BASED ON THE WARMER ECONOMY.
AND THE CHANGES THAT WE ALL
AGREE TO AN SB EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHT THE WINNER BILL LAST YEAR
AND SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE I WAS
SPEAKING TO A BAY AREA GROUP
LAST NIGHT WHERE I TOLD THEM
THAT THEIR RINA NUMBER THAT THEY
SHOULD EXPECTED TO DOUBLE.
AS A REGION BASED ON ALL OF
THOSE FACTORS WE THINK IT'S
GONNA BE A LOT.
SO WHEN WE LOOK AT THE SHORT AND
LONG TERM IF YOU TAKE THOSE
HIGHER ARENAS ARE.
NUMBERS THAT WERE LIKELY TO GET
THEIR STILL PROBABLY SHORT OF
THE THREE POINT FIVE MILLION
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS MENTIONED.
SO THERE SO WE HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT THAT GOAL IS AND IF
THAT'S WHAT THE GOAL IS THAT WE
HAVE TO CHANGE IT AND THERE'S
GONNA HAVE TO BE SOME RESOURCES
ALIGNED WITH THAT.
BUT SHORT AND LONG TERM RIGHT IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE EIGHT YOUR TO
TENURE ARENA CYCLE THAT WAS WAS
HIS WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
IS I KNOW THAT MY MEMBERS WHO
WANT TO HELP OR STRUGGLING WITH
WHAT THAT IS --
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE IDENTIFIED SOME
WAYS THAT WE THINK WE CAN DO
SOME SHORT TERM IDENTIFICATION
OF SITES AND GET UNITS ON TOP.
WILL HAPPY TO SHARE THAT AS WE
GO FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
AND THAT'S WHERE ONE ITEM NUMBER --
THREE RESPONDING TO HOMELESSNESS.
IT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
GENERAL FUND TO PROVIDE
JURISDICTIONS ONE TIME FUNDS TO
SUPPORT REGIONAL PLANNING. TO
EXPAND OR DEVELOP SHELTERS FOR
THE HOMELESS AND TO MEET
MILESTONES TOWARDS ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS IN EACH
JURISDICTION WE ANTICIPATE THE
FUNDS WILL BE PROVIDED THROUGH
THE FORTY THREE CONTINUUM'S OF
CARE AND THIRTEEN MOST POPULOUS
CITIES IN THE STATE.
BASED ON THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN HOMELESSNESS POINT IN
TIME COUNT.
JURISDICTIONS WILL BE ENCOURAGED
TO COOPERATE REGIONALLY TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS.
WHILE WE ARE STILL FINALIZING
THIS TRAVEL AS WELL I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS I CAN.
WELL.
THAT'S MORALIS WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE THE
GOVERNOR'S INTEREST INVESTING IN
SHORT TERM SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS SEEMS REASONABLE
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF RECENT
INVESTMENTS FOR PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IN.
THE SHORT TERM SOLUTIONS COULD
PROVIDE US IMMEDIATE RELIEF FOR
THESE LONGER TERM SOLUTIONS RAMP
UP.
ON THE OTHER HAND TO THE
FLEXIBLE FUN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS --
FOR FOR HOMELESSNESS --
ADVANCEMENTS IS A BIT RISKY
SIMILAR TO WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
SAID ON ITEM ONE IT'S JUST
UNCLEAR HOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WILL RESPOND AND WHETHER THE
LEGISLATURE WILL SEE ITS
INTENDED OUTCOMES.
INTO THEIR ALTERNATE USES THAT
POTENTIALLY COULD HAVE MOR
CERTAIN BENEFITS FOR THE
HOMELESS COMMUNITY IN THE STATE --
AND THEN FINALLY WILL JUST NOTE
THAT THERE'S A NUMBER OF
ADMINISTRATIVE ISSUES ALONG THE
LINES OF WHAT WE SAID ON THE
OTHER ITEMS AS WELL ABOUT HOW
THE FUNDING WILL GO OUT WHAT ARE
THE MILESTONE SIX CETERA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
QUESTION FINANCE LAST YEAR WITH
THE HE PROGRAM FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION THIS IS.
LITTLE DIFFERENT ANIMAL AND WITH.
MUCH NEED OBVIOUSLY HOME THIS IS
THE BIG ISSUE IS CONCERNED
AMONGST A LOT OF MEMBERS SO HOW
WILL THIS BE DIFFERENT AND WE WE
CAN MAKE SURE THE MONEY'S DOING
WHAT IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE DOING.
SHARE SAYS CAN THIS PROGRAM AND
IT'S IT'S A NEW PROGRAM BE
ADMINISTERED DIFFERENTLY FROM
THE HEAT PROGRAM.
WHICH IS THE HOUSING --
COORDINATING FINANCING COUNCILS
ONLY --
FUNDED PROGRAM RIGHT NOW IN
ADDITION MONITORING FOR THE HEAT
PROGRAM IS ONGOING I'M AND SO WE
DIDN'T WANT TO MIX THOSE FUNDS
AND WE DO SEE THESE AS A
DIFFERENT USE WEBER STILL I'M
WORKING OUT THE DETAILS OF THOSE
YEARS WE DO SEE THIS AS A
DIFFERENT PROGRAM WITH.
DIFFERENT TACK MILESTONES.
BUT YOU.
TO I WANT TO FOLLOW ON OUR
MISTER COOPER'S COMMENT SO SO
HEAP LAST YEAR WE HAD OUR HALF
BILLION WE GOT ANOTHER HALF
BILLION THIS YEAR ON AN ENTIRELY
NEW PROGRAM.
HOUSING CAN BE DIFFERENT.
SET AND MIGHT CALL UP THE OTHER
COLLEAGUE FROM THE HOUSING
COORDINATING FINE FOR GENERAL
PURPOSE WHERE AS THESE PROGRAM
FUNDS WILL BE TARGETED MORE --
BALLER CONSIDERING THE USE SAYS
WE KNOW THAT THEY'LL BE TARGETED
TOWARDS SHELTERS AND NAVIGATION
CENTERS.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE
ANYMORE AB ON THE HEAT PROGRAM.
OF THIS IS GINNY PARTY FOOT I'M
WITH THE HOMELESS CREATING
FINANCING COUNCIL.
OF THE HEAP FUNDS OF ALMOST ALL
BEEN DISPERSED I THINK WE HAVE
THREE MORE CEO SEES THAT ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF GETTING THEIR
FUNDS DISBURSED --
GENERALLY I CAN SAY THAT ABOUT
38% OF THE WAYS THAT STOCK
CONTINUES OF CARE HAVE PROPOSED
TO USE THOSE FUNDS ARE FOR
SERVICES. FOR HOMELESSNESS AND
ABOUT 34% ARE EARMARKED FOR
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS WHICH CAN
BE CAN INCLUDE SHELTERS AND
NAVIGATION CENTERS BUT CAN ALSO
INCLUDE OTHER KINDS OF
HOMELESSNESS --
IMPROVEMENTS AND THEN BELOW THAT
THERE IS A ABOUT. 14% FOR RENTAL
ASSISTANCE EITHER DIRECT RENTAL
SUBSIDIES OR SOME OTHER KIND OF
STUFF.
RENTAL SUPPORT AND THEN ABOUT 7%
SET ASIDE FOR YOUTH HOMELESSNESS
WHICH IS SLIGHTLY MORE THAN THE
5% THAT WAS REQUIRED IN HEAP.
AND THEN ANOTHER 4% FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS WHICH IS
LOWER THAN THE 5% ALLOWED.
AND THEN FINALLY OTHER.
IF I COULD JUST MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS SO AGAIN WHAT WE'RE
LEARNING TODAY AS WE HAD A
PROGRAM LAST YEAR BIG CHUNK OF
MONEY HASN'T BEEN ANALYZED AND
WE'RE SETTING UP AN ENTIRELY NEW
PROGRAM.
YOU KNOW FOR ME IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT EVERY DOLLAR WE SPEND AS
WELL SPENT I WOULD AGREE
DIRECTIONALLY I WOULD ABSOLUTE
SUPPORT THAT LEVEL OF FUNDING
BEING SPENT.
I THINK THE QUESTION IS AROUND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE REAL EVIDENCE BASED
DATABASE APPROACHES TO ENDING
HOMELESSNESS AND I WOULD SUGGEST
IN AND OF OF OF COURSE WE ALL
WANT TO SUPPORT SHELTERS IN
EDUCATION CENTERS --
BUT IF WHAT I'M HEARING IT MIGHT
DOLLARS IS GOING TO BE SPENT FOR
THOSE TWO PURPOSES AND NOT
NECESSARILY FOR LONG TERM
PERMANENT.
SUPPORT OF HOUSING OPTIONS WERE
WAYS TO ENSURE THAT.
WE'RE GETTING PEOPLE INTO
PERMANENT SOLUTIONS.
THOSE ARE THE TWO SOURCES ARE
THE TWO I'M INVESTMENTS THAT
WE'VE IDENTIFIED HOWEVER WE ARE
CONSIDERING OTHER --
INVESTMENTS AT THIS TIME --
AND SO THOSE WILL BE FORTHCOMING
SO A GUEST IN SHORT NOTE RIGHT
NOW THOSE ARE THE ONLY TWO WE'VE
IDENTIFIED BUT NOT THAT ONLY TWO
WERE CONSIDERED.
I THINK WHAT I WITH WOULD
SERVICE THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA RECENT YEARS WE HAVE
SPENT BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TRYING
TO TACKLE HOMELESSNESS AND
JURISDICTIONS ALL OVER THE STATE
OR SPENDING MONIES IN DIFFERENT
WAYS AND WE'RE NOT HAVING THE
IMPACT THAT WE WANT.
I WILL USE MY OWN CITY AS AN
EXAMPLE OF THAT WE'VE SPENT
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
EVERY YEAR AND YET ARE HOMELESS
NUMBERS ARE EXACTLY THE SAME AND
SO FOR ME.
ENSURING THAT WHATEVER WE DO IS
EVIDENCE BASED AND WITH THE GOAL
OF RESULTING IN GETTING PEOPLE
OUT OF SHELTERS INTO SUPPORT OF
HOUSING INTO SUPPORT OF HOUSING
SOLUTIONS THAT TO ME SHOULD BE.
HOW WE WE THINK ABOUT THIS BUT
OBVIOUSLY WE LOOK FOR DEBT TO
SING WHAT YOU GUYS PRESENT AS
FAR AS THIS PROGRAM [inaudible]
WICKS.
SIR JUST TO KIND OF PIGGY BACK
ON THAT YOU KNOW I THINK.
MANY OF US ARE LIVING THIS EVERY
DAY RIGHT IN MY COUNTIES WE'VE
HAD A 40% INCREASE IN ALMOST AS
THE LAST TWO YEARS.
I'M SURE MANY OF US HAVE GONE
AND AND COME TO SOME OF THESE
SHELTERS AND TALK TO FOLKS IN
MEANS THAT YOU SEE ALONG THE
FREEWAY UNDERNEATH FREEWAY
OVERPASSES AND IT'S
HEARTBREAKING --
AND I THINK ALL OF US ARE ARE
REALLY.
STRUGGLING HERE FOR SOLUTION AND
I I LIKE THE IDEA THAT WE'RE
GOING TO PUT RESOURCES INTO IT I
THINK WE ALL AGREE TO THAT BUT
WHAT ARE THE METRICS THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
YOU KNOW I'M JURISDICTIONS ARE
ARE MAKING PROGRESS TOWARDS
MAKING YOU KNOW PERMITTING NEW
SUPPORT OF HOUSING BUILDING THE
GOT NOT NAVIGATION CENTERS
CONSTRUCTING EMERGENCY SHELTERS.
AND THEN THAT THE APART PIECE
ABOUT LONG TERM PERMANENT
SUPPORT OF HOUSING.
WE ARE STILL WORKING THROUGH
THOSE DETAILS.
AND FOR FINANCE ON THE HE IT'S
IT'S SOME POINT REPORT BACK ON
THE MONEY ALLOCATED.
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THAT I
MEAN WE LIVED HERE.
THE TOUGH BILLION DOLLARS SO.
I WOULD BE HELPFUL. EIGHT MR
GABRIEL.
YEAH I JUST WANTED TO STRONGLY
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU
I THINK HE'S SPOT ON HERE AND
AND AND ALSO WHAT --
WOOD MISTER COOPER SAID YOU KNOW
WE THIS IS THIS IS A SERIOUS
AMOUNT OF MONEY BOTH LAST YEAR
WHAT'S BEEN PROPOSED FOR THIS
YEAR AND HAVING.
METRICS THAT WE CAN LOOK AT
EVIDENCE BASED --
THINGS THAT WE CAN SEE PER HE'S
BEING SPENT EFFECTIVELY AND
EFFICIENTLY IN IN THE RIGHT
MANNER BECAUSE AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS SAID YOU KNOW WE
HEAR ABOUT THIS ALL THE TIME IN
THERE SO MUCH ENERGY AROUND THIS
AROUND THE STATE --
IT IT REALLY IS A INCREDIBLE
MORAL CHALLENGE FOR US IN AND IN
ADDITION TO ECONOMIC CHALLENGE
AND SO TO SEE THAT WE SPEND HALF
A BILLION DOLLARS ON ONE THING
AND THEN TO IMMEDIATELY
TRANSITION TO SOMETHING ELSE
WITHOUT METRICS WITHOUT BEING
SURE ABOUT.
DEFECTIVE SET OUT OF THAT HOW
THAT MONEY IS BEING SPENT ON IS
IS IS A LITTLE GIVES US A LITTLE
BIT A PAUSE AND SO --
YOU KNOW WE'RE WE LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING WHAT THE GOVERNOR WHAT
OTHER --
INVESTMENTS YOU'RE GONNA MAKE
BUT I THINK THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT THE FOLKS ARE GONNA PAY A
LOT OF ATTENTION TO AND SO I
REALLY WANT TO ECHO WHAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU SAID ABOUT
THE THIS QUIRK SILVA --
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK I A. B.
RELATED TO HE FUNDS I KNOW THAT
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON I'M QUITE
A BIT AND I CAN SAY FOR MY
CITIES -- WE
HAVE HAD SOME OF OUR CITY'S TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE HEAP FUNDS AS A
MATTER OF FACT IN NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY WHICH IS A PRETTY TOUGH
AREA. TO GET --
TO I THINK OUR LOCAL ELECTED
INVESTED IN PURSUING STATE
FUNDING THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN --
A TOUGH -- I
THINK ARGUMENT FOR THEM TO
ACTUALLY GO TO THE STATE AND SAY
WE REALLY DO HAVE AN EMERGENCY
AND THEY DID ACTUALLY DO THAT
AND I BELIEVE RE RECEIVED ABOUT
TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT IS NOW.
BEING USED IN THE END WHAT THEY
CALL THE NORTH COUNTY SPOT AREA
SO SPA NOT LIKE SPOCK WHAT WE
MIGHT THINK BUT SPA LIKE SERVICE
PROVIDER AREA.
AND I THINK WHICH IS REALLY
INTERESTING AND IS TO SEE FROM
WHAT WE ARE DOING HERE AT THE
STATE DOWN TO THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND THAT HOW DOES THAT WORK WITH
THE CONSTITUENTS SO.
AGREEMENT WAS MADE THAT FULLER
TEN WOULD GIVE MONEY TO
PLACENTIA FOR AN EMERGENCY
SHELTER AND A BOY IN A PARK FOR
AN EMERGENCY SHELTER --
BUT RIGHT AWAY AS YOU MIGHT
SUSPECT THE WATER PARK PEOPLE
WERE LIKE HEY WHY IS FULLER TO
GETTING OFF THE HOOK AND THE
TRUTH IS FULLER CHEN AS HAD AN
ARMORY FOR THIRTY YEARS.
SO IT'S KIND OF LIKE THIS IS
YOUR TURN AND THEN PLACENTIA
IT'S BEEN A LITTLE BIT QUIET.
BUT NOW WHAT'S HAPPENING HAVING
TO GO THROUGH WHAT WE SEE A LOT
OF OUR COMMUNITIES GO THROUGH
THE PUBLIC PROCESS.
OF EVERYBODY LIKES THE IDEA
EVERYBODY WANTS THE FUNDS BUT WE
JUST DON'T WANT RIGHT THERE
THERE'S A BETTER LOCATION SO
THAT'S WHERE THEY'RE AT RIGHT
NOW WE KNOW THAT STORY.
BUT I THINK WHAT IS ENCOURAGING
IS.
IT HASN'T JUST BEEN FROM THE
LOCAL TO THE STATE IT'S ALSO A
FEDERAL JUDGE IN ORANGE COUNTY
JUDGE DAVID CARTER IN ANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES --
IT SHOULD GET TO KNOW WHO HE IS
AND WHAT HE IS DOING BECAUSE HE
IS THE GAME CHANGER IN ORANGE
COUNTY.
TO SOMETIMES USING A CARROT BUT
EVEN MORE I HAMMER RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE THE SITUATION THAT HAS
OCCURRED IN ORANGE COUNTY IS.
JUST UNCONSCIONABLE IN ADDITION
TO SO HE FINALLY SAID ALMOST A
YEAR AGO WE ARE CLEARING THIS
RIVER BANK.
AND THAT WAS ABOUT TWO THOUSAND
PEOPLE BUT HE DIDN'T HAVE A
PLACE JUST TO CLEAR THEM.
TOO SO WE KNOW THAT THEY ENDED
UP IN DIFFERENT CITIES AND MAYBE
ORIGINALLY WHERE EVER THEY WERE
FROM BUT NOW HE'S WORKED IN THE
SPOT AREAS NORTH.
CENTRAL AND SOUTH IN IS REALLY
HAS COMMITMENTS EXCEPT FOR THE
SOUTHPAW WHICH IS OUR BEACH
CITIES IS SAY NO WE'RE NOT GOING
TO DO IT.
ANNE'S SAID FINE IF YOU DON'T
WANT TO DO IT THEN HE'S NOT
GOING TO FORCE OVERNIGHT CAMPING
SO FOR ALL OF YOU I HOPE YOU
LOOK AT BECAUSE NOW HE'S ALSO
WORKING WITH THE HEALTH AGENCIES.
TO SAY WHY DID TO OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY PEOPLE DIE IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND HE HAS BROUGHT
IN SOME OF THE HEALTH PARTNERS
TO SAY WHAT ARE YOU DOING AND
WHAT YOUR ROLE.
SO I ONLY SAY THIS BECAUSE I'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS.
FROM A LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO UP
TEAR ALMOST FIFTEEN YEARS AND
EVEN MORE THAN THAT AS A AS A
TEACHER SEEN FAMILIES BEING
DISPLACED.
AND ONE PERSON WITH OTHERS
WILLING CAN MAKE THESE
DIFFERENCES BUT IT HAS TO BE.
LIKE MOST OF OUR LOOK LOCALS
DON'T LIKE CALLING THE CITIES TO
STAY AND SAY YOU'RE NOT GONNA
GET OUT OF THIS WHAT WHERE IS
YOUR SOLUTION. FOR EACH ONE AND
OF COURSE MONEY BACK TO BACK IT
UP BUT I BELIEVE THAT IF THE
IT'S HE FOR FUTURE FUNDING.
AND THEY'RE FORCED TO USE THAT
WE WILL SEE SOME RESOLUTION.
IN THE COMMENTS MISTER GLORIA.
THANK YOU SKIPPER --
SO I WANT TO CLARIFY I THINK I
KNOW THE ANSWERS BUT HEAP IS ONE
TIME ONLY GOING AWAY SAID THIS
ISN'T IT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION.
IS IN THE SAME SPACE BUT
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT.
IT'S NOT AUGMENTING ITS
REPLACING. TO DO.
BUT WITH DIFFERENT GUIDELINES
KEEP KEEP WAS ONE TIME FLEXIBLE
BLOCK GRANT FUNDING THAT'S
CORRECT AND AS I MENTIONED WE'RE
JUST ABOUT ALL OF THE FRONT THAT
FUNDING THAT FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION HAS BEEN DISPERSED.
AND SO THIS WOULD BE A NEW
CHANNEL YEAH SOME I GUESS MY
POINT IS THAT WE ARE MAINTAINING
STATUS QUO IN TERMS OF BUDGET.
FORTY FIVE MILLION LAST YEAR
FIVE MILLION THIS YEAR --
IN THAT AND SOME WAYS MAY SEEM
OUT OF SORTS TO ALL OF US WHO
HEARALL THE TIME FOR MARKETS TO
HELP SET THEY ARE ABOUT THIS AND
WANTS TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT
SO.
YOU KNOW FROM A LEVEL FUNDING
STANDPOINT THAT HAS A BIG
CONCERN BUT AGAIN APPRECIATE
THAT IS ACTUALLY IN THERE THAT
IS THE GOVERNOR PROPOSING IT YOU
KNOW IT'S ARE YOU KNOW WE CAN WE
CAN TALK ABOUT DOMINANCE.
I WANTED TO ASSOCIATE --
I WANTED --
TO TO YOU TALKED ABOUT --
THAT NAVIGATION CENTERS IN
SHELTERS ARE ALLOWED BUT THERE
ARE OTHER.
YOU YOU GET SPECIFIC NUMBERS FOR
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE ALLOWED TO
DO THIS PROGRAM UNDER HEAT
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY WHAT ABOUT
DID THESE FUNDS THESE THAT THE
FY.
NINETY TWO TWENTY SO RIGHT NOW
WE'VE IDENTIFIED EMERGENCY
SHELTERS AND NAVIGATION CENTERS
BUT WE ARE STILL CONSIDERING
OTHER POTENTIALLY I WOULD ASK
YOU NOT TO CONSIDER BUT TO DO --
BEYOND THAT --
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A MERCY
SHELTER THEY ARE NOT SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE THERE GRADUATING LESS
THAN 20% OF THE PEOPLE OUT OF
THE SHELL THE THESE TENTS --
INTO HOUSING AND THE REASON THEY
DO THIS BECAUSE THEY KNOW IT PUT
RIGHT SO THEY GET OFF THE
STREETS THAT DEMONA CLARITY TO
GET UP THE STREETS THEY GET THE
TENT -- AND
THEY HAVE NOWHERE TO GO --
WE ARE CURRENTLY USING PROBABLY
SOME HEAT FUNNY I'M NOT I'M NOT
A 100% SURE BUT WE'VE ACQUIRED A
NAVIGATION CENTER WITH ZERO
HOUSING IN IT.
AND WE CAN'T NAVIGATE THEM
ANYWHERE TO GO OUT AND THIS IS
THE KIND OF MADNESS IT'S GONNA
LOSE THE SUPPORT OF THE PEOPLE
AND IN CONTINUED SUPPORT ISSUE
ALLOCATIONS.
BELOW NEW ALLOCATIONS AND IT
UNDERMINES OUR OVERALL CONCEPT
WHICH IS THAT WE CAN IN THIS AND
WE KNOW THAT WE CAN'T BECAUSE
OTHER COUNTRIES DON'T HAVE THIS
PROBLEM QUITE TO NINETY TWO THAT
WE DO SO --
I'M HOPEFUL THAT WE HAVE A CARE
IN STATE CONVERSATION WITH
CITIES WHICH HAD CARE INSTEAD OF
RELATIVE TO HOUSING PRODUCTION
WE SHOULD HAVE THAT WITH REGARD
TO METRICS --
ON HOMELESS --
TRANSITION OFF THE STREETS --
IN NEAR AS I CAN SEE NAVIGATIONS
THERE'S A FINE TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING AND SHELTERS ARE FINE
BUT THE MISSING PART WOULD GETS
GUMMED UP IS THAT THERE'S NO WAY
TO PUT THEM BACK WITH THEM OUT
FROM THERE.
AND IF THE STATE'S NOT HELP IN
THERE AND I'M NOT SURE HOW HELP
IN -- SO I
WOULD JUST MAKE THAT THAT FAIRLY
COMMITTEE WHICH IS THAT WE CAN
BUSINESS --
AND WE STATE ECOSYSTEM OF
HOUSING OPTIONS PRINT OUR EGGS
INTO INTO BASKETS RATHER THAN
ALLMAN DOESN'T MAKE A LOT OF
SENSE TO ME.
MR THIS YEAH IN YOU KNOW.
I'M NOT SURE I CAN ADD MUCH YOU
KNOW I REALLY APPRECIATE ALL
THAT'S BEEN SAID HERE ABOUT
CREATED METRICS AND AND PROVIDED
AND IT --
AND AN EVIDENCE BASED APPROACH
MOVING FORWARD I COME FROM A
COUNTY SAN BENITO COUNTY.
WHERE WE UTILIZE THESE FINDINGS
VERY PROACTIVELY WHERE WE
CREATED A HOMELESS RESOURCE
CENTER IT'S CALLED HOME THE
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES MEALS
EMPOWERMENT RESOURCE CENTER
WHICH HAS A SHELTER?
HOUSES FIFTY MEN FIFTY WOMEN --
WE OFFER ONSITE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
EMPLOYMENT BASED SERVICES AND
YOU KNOW HAVING BEEN AWARDED
THESE GRANTS WE WANNA SEE YOU
KNOW THIS.
YOU KNOW OUR OUR OUR VISION
EXPANDED TO NO TO FILL THAT GAP
AND THE OUR COMMUNITY --
BUT I SEE THIS WHAT WE DID IN
CENTER COUNTY WE PRIORITIZE IS
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE
MY SECOND YEAR AS A SUPERVISOR
THERE IN SAN BENITO.
AND IT'S BECOME A REGIONAL MODEL
IS BECOME A REGIONAL MODEL FOR
THE COUNTY MONTEREY --
AND I SAY THAT BECAUSE I
APPRECIATE WHAT'S IN THIS REPORT
THAT YOU KNOW THIS HOMELESSNESS
ATTACKING THIS PROBLEM IS A
MULTI PRONGED APPROACH WHAT MAY
WORK AND THEN IN IN YOU KNOW
SOME PARTS OF CALIFORNIA WORKING
OTHERS.
BUT I APPRECIATE THIS FUNNY
BECAUSE I HAVE SEEN THE EVIDENCE
BASED EXAMPLES ON HOW THIS CAN
WORK ESPECIALLY IN THE RURAL
PARTS OF THE STATE YOU KNOW IN
THE DISTRICT I REPRESENT SO.
HIGH SUPPORT THIS FINDING AND
YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY WE CAN MAKE
IT WORK FOR YOU KNOW --
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE THANK
YOU MISTER TING.
THANK YOU MISTER --
JUST TO SORT OF SET THE TABLE ON
THE ON THE KEEP FINDING ONE OF
THE REASONS AND REALLY
APPRECIATE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
FOR WORK AND SO COLLABORATIVELY
AND SO QUICKLY.
THE THE WAY THE FUNDING
MECHANISM WAS CHOSEN WAS TO
REALLY WORK WITH THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE AND ALL THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES.
AND AGAIN THESE ARE THE THESE
ARE THE ORGANIZATIONS THESE ARE
THE AGENCIES THAT HAVE BEEN ON
THE FRONTLINES OF HOMELESSNESS
NOT LAST YEAR NOT LAST MONTH BUT
REALLY FOR DECADES.
AND SO HE WAS REALLY TO WORK
WITH THEM TRY TO GET THEM
RESOURCES AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
BECAUSE WE HAD AN EMERGENCY AND
TRY TO GET THOSE RESOURCES.
DEPLOYED AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
MY INITIAL CONCERN WITH THE
PROPOSAL WE WILL FIRST WAITING
FOR THE PROPOSAL WILL WILL WE
GET THE PROPOSAL --
THE BE GOOD TO GET THE DETAILS
BUT THE INITIAL CONCERT WITH
PROPOSAL IS.
WE DON'T WANT TO GET STOCK IN
THE STATE BUREAUCRATIC PROCESS
WHERE.
WE TAKE A YEAR TO DESIGN AN RF
P. WE TAKE ANOTHER YEAR TO HAVE
GRANT GUIDELINES AND THEN THREE
YEARS LATER PEOPLE APPLY IN THE
MAYBE FIVE YEARS LATER AFTER
WERE ALL GONE THE MONEY GOES OUT
THE DOOR.
SO I THINK WE WANT TO BE IN A
SITUATION --
AGAIN AND I THINK MY CAR THE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF RESOURCES
THAT.
SHOULD BE SHOULD BE QUALIFIED I
THINK WE ALL KNOW BUT THE
PROBLEM IS IS TRYING TO GET THE
RESOURCES ON THE GROUND THEY
DON'T DO US ANY GOOD SITTING
HERE IN SACRAMENTO WHEN EACH CD
OR IN FINANCE OR IN THE BANK
THEY REALLY NEED TO BE IN OUR
COUNTIES.
IN OUR CITIES AND REALLY TO
POINT AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE --
HAVING SAID THAT I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT TO ALSO WORK WITH ALL
THE DIFFERENT GRASSROOTS AND
GOVERNMENT GROUPS ARE ON THE
GROUND REALLY UNDERSTANDING WHAT
THEIR NEEDS ARE AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN BENITO SAID.
WHILE -- I
KNOW ONE OF OUR MAJOR POWERS A
SAN FRANCISCO HAS BEEN AROUND
NAVIGATION CENTERS AND SHELTERS
IN GETTING THOSE UP OTHER OTHER
PEOPLE HAVE.
DIFFERENT NEEDS ARE IN DIFFERENT
PLACES.
ROAD REALLY NEED DIFFERENT
SOLUTION SO AGAIN.
ACTUALLY TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THOSE SOLUTIONS ARE AND
WHERE THEY NEED TO GO AND THAT'S
PARTLY WHY.
WE WE GAVE DIFFERENT LOCATIONS
SOME LEVEL OF FLEXIBILITY SO
WASN'T COMPLETELY SO
PRESCRIPTIVE FROM SACRAMENTO
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE TIME.
TO DO A FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
ANALYSIS WILLING TO STAND WHAT'S
THE BEST SOLUTION EVERY SO
COUNTY.
THE PEACE BECAUSE BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FULLERTON AND
REALLY WHAT SHE SAID WHICH IS.
WHILE THE MONEY GOT TO THE
DIFFERENT LOCALES PART OF REALLY
WHAT IS STOPPING THE PLACEMENT
OF SERVICES OR SHELTERS OR
NAVIGATION CENTERS OR PURPOSE
PARTY HOUSING IS ALL THE NAME
BSM.
SO WHAT ONE THING I REALLY --
ENCOURAGE US ALL TO GIVING.
GIVING --
LOCALS RESOURCES WHO ARE REALLY
WILLING TO STREAMLINE THIS
PROCESS MOVE THIS PROCESS.
VERY VERY QUICKLY --
I DID LEGISLATION FOR FROM MY
CITY AND A COUPLE OTHER CITIES
UP AND DOWN THE STATE INCLUDING
LA AND OAKLAND AND BERKELEY. TO
KIND OF STREAMLINED THE PROCESS
FOR HOMELESS SHELTERS BUT REALLY --
IF WE'RE GOING TO PUT MORE
RESOURCES WE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER.
ATTACHING THAT STREAMLINING TO
TO THIS MONEY SO THAT WE KNOW
THAT THE SHELTERS OR THE HOUSING
WILL GET BETTER BUILT ASAP
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T LIKE I SAID
IT DOESN'T DO US ANY GOOD FOR TO
BE BUILT FIVE YEARS NOW.
WE REALLY NEED THIS TO HAPPEN
NOW.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
WE'LL AND TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT.
WE'VE GOT THIS [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
YOU COULD.
AFTERNOON SHARON REPORT WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING --
THAT WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING THIS PROPOSAL
RECORD REPRESENTS WE ARE
DISAPPOINTED IN THE SHORT TERM
THINKING IT REPRESENTS --
WE DO NEED LONG TERM THINKING TO
ADDRESS THIS --
PROBLEM AND USING --
EVIDENCE BASED SOLUTIONS AS A
NUMBER OF YOU HAVE SUGGESTED.
WE CAN GET PEOPLE HOUSE QUICKLY
THROUGH IT'S IN THE PRIVATE
MARKET.
AND THROUGH OPERATING SUBSIDIES
FOR AFFORDABLE AND SUPPORT OF
HOUSING THAT ALREADY EXISTS OR
THAT IS COMING ONLINE --
WE ALSO NEED COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS SPECIFIC
PHONY OF SPECIFICALLY VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS SUCH AS YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
AND WHILE WE NEED INTERMINABLE
ENGINES LIKE SHELTERS TO GET
PEOPLE ACCESS TO SERVICES TO
CONNECT THEM TO PERMANENT
HOUSING --
WE DO NOT NEED TO SHUT TO SEE
SHELTERS AS A SOLUTION --
IN FACT. ONE OF THE REASONS ONE
OF THE BIGGEST REASONS WHY WE
HAVE SO MANY AND SHELTER PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA'S BECAUSE WE HAVE
NO FLOW OUT OF THE SHELTERS AND
INTO PERMANENT HOUSING.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA
SUGGESTED.
OF FINALLY EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT
WE SHOULD NEVER SEE SHELTER AS A
SOLUTION IT IS NOT A SOLUTION TO
HOMELESSNESS --
EVIDENCE SHOWS THE HOUSING IS A
SOLUTION TO HOMELESSNESS AND I
THINK A NUMBER OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MADE THAT POINT REALLY --
REALLY WELL --
WE'VE HAD TOO MANY YEARS OF
SHORT TERM SOLUTIONS AND WE NOW
NEED LONG TERM SOLUTIONS TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS.
AND I WOULD JUST COMMEND --
A FOR A. B. --
EIGHT SIXTEEN AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAY AS FOR US --
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE ZERO SEVEN
BOTH OF THOSE PROPOSALS INCLUDE
BUDGET PROPOSALS THAT REALLY DO --
FUNDS LONG TERM SOLUTIONS AND
STRATEGIES TO GET PEOPLE OFF THE
STREETS PERMANENTLY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU CHRIS MARTIN WITH
HOUSING CALIFORNIA --
AGAIN WE'RE REALLY EXCITED TO
SEE THE INVESTMENT PROPOSED BY
THE GOVERNOR IN THE BUDGET BUT
HAVE CONCERNS --
AS HAS BEEN MENTIONEDABOUT THE
STRATEGIES TO BE FUNDED AND
AGREE WITH THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER
AS TO SHELTERS NOT BEING THE
SOLUTION TO TO HOMELESSNESS.
AS THE GOVERNOR STATED IN HIS
STATE OF THE STATE ADDRESS
SHELTERS SOLVE SLEEP HOUSING AND
SERVICES SOLVE HOMELESSNESS --
BUT WE CAN AND WE CAN MEET THE
IMMEDIATE NEED OF PEOPLE LIVING
ON OUR STREETS.
THROUGH RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND
OPERATING SUBSIDIES --
PROPOSED THROUGH AB EIGHT ONE
SIX WHICH EMBRACE BRACES BOTH
THE GOVERNOR'S GOALS OF REGIONAL
COLLABORATION --
AND TRULY A HOUSING FOR STRATEGY --
MENTIONS THAT IT MAKES SENSE TO
INVEST IN SHORT TERM ASSISTANCE
WHILE WE WAIT FOR NO PLACE LIKE
HOME FUNDS TO RAMP UP.
AND AS I SAID EARLIER RENTAL
ASSISTANCE COULD BE THAT SHORT
TERM SOLUTION --
IT BUT NO PLACE LIKE HOME COVERS
ONE SPECIFIC POPULATION --
OF ARE HOMELESS.
LUCIEN AND NEARLY A HUNDRED
THOUSAND OTHER PEOPLE ARE
MISSING THE BALL.
AND SO WE NEED TO REALLY BE
THINKING ABOUT LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS FOR THE OTHER PEOPLE
THAT ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN OUR IN OUR STATE.
AND ALSO WE NEED A ROBUST
INVESTMENT --
IN YOUTH HOMELESSNESS AS STATED
EARLIER AND FULLY ENDORSE THE
STRATEGIES AND AB THREE OR SEVEN
TH.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN LAWYERS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YEARS AND I JUST
WAS A REALLY APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION FROM ALL THE MEMBERS
TODAY.
AND LOOK FOR TO WEIGHING IN ON
THE DETAILS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND WE REALLY DO NEED
LONG TERM SOLUTIONS ESPECIALLY
FOR YEARS THEM BECAUSE THEY ARE
FUTURE AND IF.
WE DON'T SERVE THEM OTHER YOUTH
THEY WILL BECOME OUR CHRONIC
FUTURE POPULATION WE KNOW THAT
IN SAN FRANCISCO FOR EXAMPLE 50%
OF THE CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
POPULATION FIRST EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS WHEN THEY WERE
UNDER.
TWENTY FIVE THE IF STATES
INVESTMENT AND ON GOING FUNDS
AND PROGRAMS FOR YOU IS UNDER
TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
SO SADLY IT'S NOT SURPRISING TO
ME TODAY THAT WE HAVE THE
PROBLEM THAT WE DO AROUND
CHRONICALLY IT.
KIND OF HOMELESSNESS AND
HOMELESSNESS IN GENERAL AND THEN
IT REALLY ENCOURAGES
LEGISLATURE'S STEP UP AND REALLY --
AUGMENTS SOME FUNDING FOR ON
GOING PRO LIKELY HOMELESS
POPULATION AND WE REALLY NEED TO
MARRY THE OPTIONS ARE RAY AND
REYES OF HOUSING AND SERVICES TO
SUPPORT THEM.
AND TRANSITION THEM AND WE KNOW
THERE'S ALL THIS RESEARCH AROUND
BRAIN DEVELOPMENT AS THEY'RE
GROWING UP UNTIL THE AGE OF
TWENTY FIVE AND TEN ALSO NOT
FORGET THE NEEDS OF YOUTH THAT
ARE ALSO PARENTING AND PREGNANT
THING.
AS THEIR YOUTH THEMSELVES SO IT
REALLY HOPE THAT WE CAN WEIGH IN
ON THE CONVERSATION ON ONCE MORE
DETAILS COMMAND AND WOULD ALSO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO THINK ABOUT YOU
CENTERED CORNING ENTRY SYSTEM
SPECIFICALLY --
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T HAVE THOSE
TOOLS AND TO IDENTIFY YOU
THEY'RE NEVER GOING TO BE REALLY
ABLE TO COMPETE WITH THE CHRONIC
POPULATION AND CORE NEED ENTRY.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
SEVENTEEN YEARS ON THE STREET
BEFORE THEY CAN COME THE TOP OF
THE LIST AND THAT'S NOT WHAT WE
WANT TO DO FOR YOU --
AND WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO SOLVE
AND ADDRESS THEIR IMMEDIATE
NEEDS QUICK LEARNER SO THAT WE
CAN PREVENT THIS MOMENT THANK
YOU.
HI TAMMY MARTIN FOR EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA THE NATION'S LARGEST
STATEWIDE LGBT Q. CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION AND PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THE PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO COMBAT USE
HOMELESSNESS.
A DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER
APPROXIMATELY 40% OF HOMELESS
YOUTH IDENTIFY AS LGBTQ.
SO I'D LIKE TO ASSOCIATE MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF MY CO
SPONSOR CAM LEWIS AND URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
CAN REALLY ROSENBERGER WAS
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION WERE SUPPORTIVE OF EFFORTS
TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS BUT WE
WOULD URGE THAT YOU ARE NOT
CREATE A NEW PROGRAM THAT USE
EXISTING RESOURCES.
WE BELIEVE A LONG TERM SOLUTION
MUST INCLUDE PUBLIC SAFETY NET
RESOURCES IN COUNTY SERVICES AT
THE SIGHT OF LOW INCOME HOUSING
AS WELL AS IN THE STREETS WITH
OUR WORKERS OUT STATIONED --
OUR MEMBERS HAVE THE TOOLS AND
FORTY FOR IMMEDIATE SERVICE
DELIVERY EXPANDING ACCESS TO
THESE WARS RESOURCE OF APPLE
LOCATION WOULD INCREASE
PARTICIPATION ENSURE THE NEW YES
ARE SEEING THE BENEFITS YOU
DESERVE.
BY PLACING ARE COUNTY WORKERS ON
LOCATION AS NAVIGATORS WILL BE
ABLE TO COORDINATE WITH OTHER
COUNTY SERVICES.
REMOVE BARRIERS TO ACCESS --
UTILIZE EXISTING RESOURCES AND
WORK WITH IN THE COUNTY SERVICE
SYSTEM SO THAT THEY CAN GET --
ACCESS TO FOOD JUST HOUSING
WEEPING SHELTERS IMPORTANT BUT
IT'S JUST STEP ONE IN ADDRESSING
THE HOMELESSNESS THINKS.
OU.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THE COUNTY HAS SPENT
MANY YEARS ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS AND HAS IMPROVED IT
DRASTICALLY WE APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE'S AND THE GOVERNOR'S
ATTENTION AND INVESTMENTS --
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE CONCEPT
OF INCLUDING MILESTONES AS PART
OF THE FUNDING.
AS WELL AS FLEXIBILITY FOR
LOCALS AND WE BELIEVE THAT ANY
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SHOULD GO
THROUGH ALREADY --
IMPLEMENTED PROCESSES SUCH AS HE
OR THE CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY
SOLUTIONS AND HOUSING.
THANK YOU.
LOUIS BROWN TO AND WE HAVE A
CALIFORNIA BE --
ONE ECHO SIMILAR SUPPORT FOR THE
LEVEL FUNDING --
MAY ENCOURAGE YOU --
IN IN THE FUTURE TO INCREASE
THAT THAT LEVEL FUNDING AND MAKE
IT ON GOING --
BUT BUT AND AND WANTED TO ECHO
SIMILAR CONCERNS ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION HERE --
HOWEVER DID WANT TO STRESS THE
IMPORTANCE OF SHELTER TO
CALIFORNIANS --
CALIFORNIA MAY DEPENDS ON HOW
YOU COUNT HAVE A MORE ON
CHILDREN HOMELESS PEOPLE THAN
ALL OTHER STATES IN THE COUNTRY
COMBINED.
THE RATE OF ON CHILDREN
HOMELESSNESS IN IN THE STATE IS
ACTUALLY A VERY UNIQUE
PHENOMENON --
IN IN IN OTHER PLACES WHERE --
MOST HOMELESS FOLKS ARE
SHELTERED AT THE RATES OF
DOMESTIC ABUSE AMONG HOMELESS
PEOPLE THE RATES MON --
OF THINGS LIKE DRUG USE AND AND
THERE IS THAT I THINK THE
ASSEMBLY FINDS TO BE VERY
IMPORTANT TO THE OUTCOMES OF OF
CALIFORNIANS LIES.
ARE MUCH LOWER --
THAT THAT THAT LIFE IN IN A IN
IN A SHELTER IS MUCH BETTER THAN
A AND IT IT NOT IN.
ONE ADEPTLY ONE ECHO THE FACT
THAT --
HOUSING.
IS THE SOLUTION TO HOMELESSNESS
IS THE ULTIMATE SOLUTION
HOMELESSNESS BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE THE
STRONG BENEFIT THAT SHELTER DOES.
NOT CONVEY AND THE VERY LOW RATE
OF SHELTER IN CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
REBECCA MARCUS ON BEHALF OF
LEADING AGE CALIFORNIA WE WOULD
JUST LIKE TO URGE THAT ANY
PLANNING --
FOR SPENDING ON HOMELESSNESS
MUST ALSO INCLUDE A PRIORITY FOR
HELPING HOMELESS SENIORS THE
LARGEST GROWING DEMOGRAPHIC OVER
HOMELESS POPULATION HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
MUCH OF THE NEW FUNDING FOR HOME
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS CANNOT
BE BUILT ARE USED FOR A SENIOR
HOUSING SENIORS HAVE MORE
COMPLEX HEALTH NEEDS INCLUDING A
HIGHER LIKELIHOOD OF HAVING TWO
OR MORE CHRONIC CONDITIONS.
AT A MUCH HIGHER RATE OF
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENT WHICH IS
NOT CONSIDERED A MENTAL HEALTH
DIAGNOSIS UNDER MANY OF THE
HOUSING PROGRAMS THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES ALSO WHEN APPLIED THE
GOVERNOR FOR THE CONTINUING
RECOGNITION THAT STATE FUNDING
IS NECESSARY TO HELP SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM.
WANNA TALK ABOUT A FEW OF THE
THINGS FROM LAST YEAR'S
ALLOCATIONS THAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE CONTINUED --
FIRST OFF WHEN THE THANK YOU FOR
THE SPEED WITH WHICH RESOURCES
WERE ALLOCATED.
THE FLEXIBILITY --
WE TELL A LINE BETWEEN THE
FLEXIBILITY TO MEET LOCAL NEEDS
AND ALSO ADDRESS BEST PRACTICES
AND AN EVIDENCE BASED YOU KNOW
TECHNIQUES THAT WE KNOW OUR
SUCCESSFUL BUT WE THINK THAT HE
PROGRAM DID A GOOD JOB OF THAT.
AND FINALLY WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE
COLLABORATION AND SO THE
ALLOCATIONS TO THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE WHERE YOU HAVE THE CITIES
WHO ARE LARGELY RESPONSIBLE FOR
CITING THE COUNTIES WHO ARE
LARGELY RESPONSIBLE FOR SERVICES.
AND IN THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE OFTEN THE
PEOPLE ON THE FRONT LINES ALL
WORKING TOGETHER TO ALLOCATE THE
RESOURCES IS AN IMPORTANT THING
TO EMULATE --
FINALLY WE THINK THE FORMULA
ALLOCATIONS THAT ACCOMPANIED
THOSE THIS CONTINUUM OF CARE
ALLOCATIONS ARE AN IMPORTANT
FACTOR WE SHOULD EMULATE THIS
YEAR.
THANK YOU.
IT AT THE NAME IS THE CHAIR
MEMBERS MARK THE GUERRERO
REPRESENTED THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS JUST
WANT -- TO
PROVIDE YOU A COUPLE OF UPDATES
AND FEEDBACK ON WHAT WE
EXPERIENCE WITH THE STATE'S HE
DOLLARS --
SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY HAS BUILT A POWERFUL
COUNTY WIDE MOVEMENT TO PREVENT
IN COMBAT HOMELESSNESS.
AND WITH THE STATES HE FUNDING
ALLOCATED.
IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
SUPPLEMENTING OUR MEASURE H. --
FUNDING IN MANY IMPORTANT WAYS
PARTICULARLY FOR PAYING FOR BOTH
CAPITAL AND OPERATING COSTS FOR
IN TURN HOUSING.
AS WE LOOK AT LOOK AS WE LOOK AT
MOVING FRWARD TO RENEWING --
FUNDING --
NEEDS WE WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
SOME FEEDBACK ON MAXIMIZING ONE
TIME FUNDED INDEED OF WHICH THE
FUNDING CAN BE SPENT BASED ON
THE OVERALL AMOUNT OF FUNDING
AND THE TIMELINE FOR EXPENDITURE
OF THE CURRENT HEAT FUNDS.
AUTHORIZED NEW STATE FUNDING TO
BE UTILIZED FOR RAPID RE HOUSING
AS WELL AS IN TERM HOUSING AND
EDUCATION CENTERS.
RAPID RE HOUSING IS LESS
EXPENSIVE THAN SHELTER AND
PROVIDES PERMITTED HOUSING TO
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS.
HAVE ANY ABILITY TO BALANCE
INCREASES IN IN TERM HOUSING AND
RAPID RE HOUSING IS CRITICAL.
OTHERWISE THEY WILL BE MANY
PEOPLE STUCK IN IN TERM HOUSING
FOR AN EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME.
AND IN AND ENSURE THAT ANY NEW
STATE FUNDING IS ALLOCATED
GEOGRAPHICALLY BASED ON NEED AND
WE AS REFLECTED IN THE ANNUAL
HOME DISCOUNT.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU AS WE MOVE FORWARD ON
PLAN FOR HOMELESSNESS.
THANK YOU.
NEXT REMOVE ON ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
EXPANDED STATE TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
TO EXPAND THE STATE'S LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT PROGRAM IN
NINETEEN TWENTY UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION AND FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION ANNUALLY ON THEIR AFTER.
UPON APPROPRIATION AS MENTIONED
THE AGENDA AT THE ADDITIONAL
AUTHORITY INCLUDES THREE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR EXISTING STATE TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM.
TARGETED AT NEW CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS THAT PAIR WITH THE
UNDER UTILIZED 4% FEDERAL TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM.
THE REMAINING TWO HUNDRED
MILLION WILL BE ALLOCATED THREE
NEW PROGRAM THE TARGETS MIXED
INCOME HOUSING WE'RE STILL WE'RE
STILL WORK ON THE DETAILS OF
THAT PROGRAM BUT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS I CAN.
L. L.. ONE SECOND OF THIS MODEL
IS WITH THE LA --
BUT WE'LL JUST RAISES SOME
QUESTIONS FOR US ABOUT WHAT
POPULATIONS TO PRIORITIZE WITH
THIS FUNDING WELL THERE'S
CERTAINLY SOME NEED AMONG THE
MIDDLE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
BECAUSE THE NEED FOR ASSISTANCE
AMONG LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
OUTSTRIPS AVAILABLE RESOURCES
AND LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS HAVE
ACCESS TO IF YOU'RE OPTIONS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE WOULD SUCH
AS THE LEGISLATURE PRIORITIZE
STATE RESOURCES TOWARDS THAT
POPULATION RATHER THAN --
BROADENING OUT THE INCOME LEVELS --
AND THEN IN ADDITION WITH
EXAMPLES OF THE REASONS WHY SHIN.
SO -- WHILE
ON THE ONE HAND THE FUNDED
POTENTIALLY COULD BE RELEASED
IMMEDIATELY WHICH WOULD REFLECT
THE THE CRISIS BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE.
ON THE OTHER HAND A NUMBER OF
OTHER RESOURCES HAVE BEEN PLACED
TOWARDS BILL BUT TAX CREDIT
PROGRAMS IN THE RECENT YEARS.
AND SO ONE OPTION WOULD BE TO
DELAY THE FUNDING --
RELEASE AND THE COULD SENSUALLY
SERVE AS A BACKSTOP TO USE LATER
FOR EXAMPLE --
IN A SITUATION WHERE THE ECONOMY
WERE WEAKER --
THERE'S ALSO QUESTIONS ABOUT
LONG TERM FUNDING FOR THE
MAINTENANCE COSTS OF THE
AFFORDABLE UNITS THAT WOULD BE
BUILT UNDER THIS --
IF THERE'S NO DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE MAINTENANCE COSTS THE
LEGISLATURE COULD SEE IT'S A
GAINES ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING
GLOSSED OVER TIME --
AND THEN FINALLY AS NOTED YOU
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF THE
DETAILS THAT ARE YET TO BE
DEVELOPED AND SO.
A LOT OF THE QUESTIONS YOU'VE
BEEN ASKING ABOUT IMPLEMENTATION
STAND HERE AS WELL.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
RICHARD.
I WANT TO THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR
PROPOSING --
THE HALF BILLION DOLLARS FOR
THIS TAX CREDIT IN A TEXT WITH A
POLICY IS SO.
OFTEN PUT PEOPLE TO SLEEP BUT
THIS IS FOR ME PROBABLY THE MOST
A PROPOSED --
I'VE ONLY INTRODUCED ONE BILL
FIVE TIMES IN A ROW HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE THAT IS TO
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPAND THE TAX
CREDIT SO THANK YOU --
AND I ALSO WANT TO SAY THE LAST
TIME WE PUT THIS ON THE LAST
GOVERNOR'S DESK BEFORE HIS VETO
WE HAD BIPARTISAN UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT SO YOU'RE GONNA GET A
LOT OF SUPPORT FOR THAT
EXPANSION.
I'VE TWO COMMENTS FROM A POLICY
STANDPOINT AND WE HAD
REINTRODUCE FOR THE FIFTH TIME
IN EXPANSION FOR A HOUSING TAX
CREDIT IN AB TEN WITH THE
SUPPORT OF MANY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES --
IN DECEMBER BEFORE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND ANY BE
TEN THEIR WITH THEIR TWO THINGS
I WANT TO JUST HIGHLIGHT --
ONE AS YOU KNOW THERE'S A CAP ON
INDIVIDUAL INVESTORS AT SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS AND IF YOU
WERE TO REMOVE THAT CAP IT
ACTUALLY WOULD EXPAND THE MARKET
FOR THE TAX CREDIT.
AND COULD RAISE THE VALUE OF
THAT CREDIT OVER A DOLLAR SO --
WOULD LOVE TO ENGAGE WITH THE
MINISTRATION ON DOING THAT I
THINK IT'S A VERY EASY WAY.
TO MAKE THAT TAX CREDIT GO
FARTHER ON THE SECOND ONE AS HE
WANTED PIGGY BACK ON WHAT THE LA --
WAS ASKED WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING IS
TO CREATE A NEW PROGRAM THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
EXISTING PROGRAM TO A MILLION
DOLLARS TO GET AT 6280% OF AM I
AND AS AS YOU KNOW THERE IS
CURRENTLY --
AS THE UNITS ARE SERVING HOUSE
IT INCOME AVERAGING WOULD ALLOW.
HOUSEHOLDS AND EARN UP 280% A MY
TO BE PART OF THIS AS LONG AS
THE AVERAGE IS NO MORE THAN 60%.
I HAVE TO ASK WHY YOU FEEL
NECESSITY TO CREATE AN ENTIRELY
NEW PROGRAM WHEN WE ALREADY HAVE
INCOME AVERAGING EMBEDDED IN
THIS I THINK THAT SORRY TRYING
TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT --
GETTING INTO SOME OF THE THE THE
HIGHER INCOME CHALLENGES THAT
WE'VE BEEN SEEN AROUND THE FOR
BY HOUSING PROGRAMS.
SURE SO WE UNDERSTAND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CHANGE THE
ROLE IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
WITH RESPECT TO THE INCOME
AVERAGING CHING THEM SORRY.
WHICH WILL HELP FACILITATE THE
FOCUS WITH INDIVIDUALS WITH 68%
I AM I AM I HOWEVER WE'RE
BUILDING AND WE WANT TO BUILD
AND FLEXIBILITY TO EXPLAIN THIS
BAND THIS PROGRAM. TO
INDIVIDUALS WITH A HIGHER A MY
OKAY I I HAVE TO MIDNIGHT I
THINK --
INCOME AVERAGING IS ONE OF THE
VERY FEW THINGS THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION DID THAT MADE A
LITTLE BIT OF SENSE --
BUT I THINK SAYING THAT AN
ENTIRE POT OF MONEY TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IS GOING TO GO
TO THIS CATEGORY WHEN THERE ARE.
ONE AND A HALF MILLION OF
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA --
THEY'RE TRYING TO GET ACCESS TO
THE 60% AND MY BELOW I'M NOT
SURE IF THAT WOULD MAKE SENSE SO
I I WOULD BE HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN
MORE OF A CONVERSATION I THINK
THERE ARE OTHER WAYS TO GET AT
THAT.
AIM ON A BAND THAT WOULD BE MORE --
EFFICIENT AS FAR AS THE USE OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS SO HAPPY TO
ENGAGE IN THAT BUT I WANT TO
JUST PROVIDE THAT FEEDBACK.
MISTER GLORIA THANK HIM OF ITS
CHAIRMAN I JUST WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF A CHALLENGE TO ON ON
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE YOU'RE ONE
OF THE MORE AT PROBABLY AFTER
THE GENERAL DISTRESS ABOUT OUR
HOMES TO SITUATION THE MOST
COMMON HOME HOUSING QUITE A
COMPLAINT I RECEIVE.
IS FROM FOLKS WHO MAKE TOO MUCH
TO QUALIFY FOR ANY PARTICULAR
PROGRAM --
BUT WHO DON'T --
WHO CANNOT AFFORD THEM PRODUCING
ON IT SO THIS FOCUS ON --
BUYER INCOME MIDDLE INCOME
HOUSING I THINK IS IMPORTANT.
PROJECT CO AUTHOR --
THIS CHOOSE LEGISLATION SPEAKS
SOME OF THIS --
I WOULD JUST ONE OBSERVATION IS
AS WE CREATE THESE DIFFERENT
POTS OF MONEY IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT TIME IS MONEY.
THAT WE SEND A LOT OF DEVELOPERS --
ALL OVER SACRAMENTO ASKING
DIFFERENT SEGMENTS OF THE STATE
WHETHER IT'S THE TREASURER'S
OFFICE EIGHT CD.
OF THE STREET BOTH COUNTS ON
OTHERS --
YOU KNOW THAT'S TIME THAT'S
EXPENSE THAT'S ALL AND WE'RE
TRYING TO PUT MONEY IN GET MONEY
OUT THE DOOR --
AND AND REDUCE COSTS IT WOULD
SEEM TO ME THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE A LONG
TERM VISION FOR ADMINISTRATION
AS THE ABILITY BE A FOR QUITE
SOME TIME. TO LOOK AT
CONSOLIDATING STREAMLINING AND
MAYBE CENTRALIZING --
THOSE --
THAT APPROVAL PROCESS IN ORDER
TO GET MORE PRODUCTION GET MORE
UNITS HELP OUR FAMILIES --
IN THE LAST SIX ABOUT TO LEAVE
IT FOR REDUCING THE FOR THE BALL --
NOTED ANY FOR THE QUOTE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MITCHELL
FELL.
SPEAKING FOR THE FEW AND THE
PROUD THIS IS AN EXCELLENT%
BIPARTISAN BILL AND I BELIEVE IT
WILL HAVE EXCELLENT SUPPORT AND
HOPEFULLY THE GOVERNOR WILL
AGREE.
THANK YOU.
KILL GOING UP UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT.
YEAH.
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON DOESN'T
MATTER NOT WITH WHITE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA --
I'M HERE TODAY AT TWO TO EXPRESS
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE INCREASED.
TAX CREDIT ALLOCATION AND REALLY
REQUEST THAT A PORTION OF THESE
NEW FUNDS BE ALLOCATED
SPECIFICALLY FOR HOME OWNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES.
MANY HOMEOWNERSHIP --
OWNER OCCUPIED DEVELOPMENTS ARE
NOT CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE --
FOR THE LOW INCOME TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM AND WE ARE WORKING WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON ON AB.
EIGHT THIRTY TWO TWO I REALLY
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND WOULD
REALLY HOPE. FOR SUPPORT FROM
THE COMMITTEE AND FROM THE
GOVERNOR ON GOOD AFTERNOON
MARINO MIGHT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM --
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR FOR THAT
FIFTY TIMES.
OF THE BILL MENTION BY FAMILY
MEMBERS TO AN ACT OF THE
COMMENTS THAT HE MADE EARLIER --
JUST WANT TO KIND OF HIGHLIGHTS
THE ANY --
FROM A DEVELOPER'S PERSPECTIVE
THE CHALLENGE THAT WOULD BE
PLACE AND HAVING THE BIFURCATION
OF THE TWO PROGRAMS WITH A
SPECIFIC BAN AT SIXTY TO EIGHTY
WOULD MAKE IT HARDER TO PAIR.
THE STATE TAX CREDIT WITH THE
FEDERAL TAX CREDIT THERE BY
MAKING THE COST SORT OF THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY YOU HAVE TO PUT
INTO EACH --
UNIT FROM THE STATE POOL MUCH
HIGHER --
AND SO FOR LIKE EFFICIENCY
PURPOSES IT WOULD BE REALLY
VALUABLE TO HAVE IT BE IN ONE
THE ONE PART OF MONEY IN
EXISTING PROGRAM --
AND THE SECOND IS THAT FOR THE
ONE TIME MONEY THIS TO BE A
GREAT WAY TO FIND SORT OF THE 9%
PROGRAM PROJECTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY OVERSUBSCRIBED HOWEVER
WITHOUT AN ON GOING EXPECTATION.
OF TAX CREDITS COMING DOWN THE
PIPELINE DOWN THE ROAD --
DEVELOPERS CAN ACTUALLY PLAN FOR
FUTURE PROJECTS TO UTILIZE THE
CREDIT MAKING IT REALLY HARD TO
THAN BILL THIS PIPELINE OF
PROJECTS THAT ARE READY TO GO
WHEN THE CREDIT BECOME AVAILABLE --
SO WE REALLY URGE THE
ADMINISTRATION REDDIT INCREASE
THANK YOU.
I LOSE MY TAPE FROM CALIFORNIA
BE --
ECHOING THAT DESIRE FOR A LONG
TERM I THINK BETWEEN AB TEN AND
THIS PROPOSAL ARE PREFERENCES
FOR AB --
TEN IN IN IN IN LARGE PART FOR
THAT WERE WERE HUNDREDS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS SHORT.
AND ARE FOR A HOUSING AT NEEDS
AND SO THAT THAT PROBLEMS NOT
GOING ANYWHERE.
ANYTIME SOON SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
IF YOU JUST WANT TO ECHO AT AND
I'VE I DID FORGET TO MENTION THE
POINT THAT WAS JUST MADE A
PUBLIC COMMENT ABOUT HOW THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN AB TEN AND
WHAT -- THE
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSED OBVIOUSLY
DEMONSTRATION AS PROPOSED ONE
TIME DOLLARS.
LESS AGAIN FOR THE PIPELINE THE
LONG TERM PIE PLATE OF BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IF WE DON'T
HAVE PREDICTABILITY INTO THE
FUTURE WHAT AB TEN PROPOSED IS
THAT WE SPEND FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR INTO THE FUTURE
SO THAT --
DEVELOPERS CAN KNOW THAT THEY
CAN COUNT ON US ARE WORKING ON
PIPELINE PROJECTS A POSSIBILITY
OF PERRIN ST DOLLARS WITH LOCAL
DOLLARS AND FEDERAL FOR A 9% TAX
CREDITS --
OBVIOUSLY THE AMOUNT IS ONE THAT
WE NEED TO DISCUSS GIVEN THE
BUDGET REALITIES THAT WE HAVE --
BUT I THINK THINKING ABOUT NOT
JUST THIS YEAR BUT WHAT COULD WE
COMMIT TO THIS YEAR THAT WILL
HELP US --
GIVE HOUSING THE HOUSING
COMMUNITY SOME CERTAINTY IN THE
FUTURE I THINK IS A CONVERSATION
THAT IS IMPORTANT HAVE --
IN THIS FISCAL YEAR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY REMOVAL UNDERWATER NUMBER
FIVE MODERATE INCOME HOUSING
PRODUCTION.
JERRY AT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES TO INVEST FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME IN
DEVELOPMENT OF HOUSING FOR
MODERATE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS --
THIS WILL EXPAND THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCIES
EXISTING MIXED INCOME HOUSING
LOAN PROGRAM.
AND SO THIS IS AN EXISTING
PROGRAM JUST ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FROM THE GENERAL FUND AND WE BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS WE
CAN AT THIS TIME.
L. L..
A SIMILAR TO MY COMMENT ON THE
PRIOR ITEM THAT ALSO RAISES
QUESTIONS FOR US ABOUT WHICH
POPULATIONS TO PRIORITIZE IF YOU
ALLOCATE.
OF FUNDING TO ADDRESS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND THEN IF THE
LEGISLATURE TO MOVE FORWARD YOU
ALSO HAVE TO ADDRESS THE SAME
SORT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT.
TIMELINE FOR EXAMPLE.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
RESEARCH YOU.
THINK THE ONE COMMENT I WOULD
ADD IN AND UNFORTUNATELY STIR
GLORIA HAD TO LEAVE AND HE
CHAIRS ARE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
HOW WE ADDRESS THE SO CALLED
MISSING MIDDLE.
WE ALL KNOW THAT BUILDING
MISSING MIDDLE HOUSING IS
CRITICAL IT'S NOT BEING BUILT
TODAY AND WHAT WE'RE REFERRING
TO IS A HOUSING THAT --
IT NEEDS TO BE BILL TO ADDRESS A
HUGE POPULATION OF THAT MAKES A
LITTLE BIT TOO MUCH MONEY TO
QUALIFY FOR FOR WILL HOUSING --
BUT DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH INCOME
TO PURCHASE CURRENTLY PRODUCED
MARKET RATE --
I THINK I WOULD JUST I WOULD
JUST SORT OF OBSERVE BUILDING
THESE UNITS ARE EXPENSIVE
BECAUSE THERE AREN'T OTHER
SUBSIDIES ARE FEDERAL SUBSIDIES
WE CAN USE ON THIS --
AND HI I I LIKE THE IDEA OF US
INVESTING MONEY IN THIS CURRENT
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM I KNOW
IS FORTY THREE MILLION.
YOU'RE PROPOSING THAT GOES UP TO
HALF A BILLION DOLLARS I THINK
WE JUST HAVE TO THINK AGAIN OF
WHAT'S THE BEST USED FOR THE
SUBSIDY --
AND I DO I DO THINK THERE ARE
OTHER IDEAS THAT ARE OUT THERE
THAT COULD LEVERAGE PRIVATE
SECTOR RESOURCES --
IN A MORE SIGNIFICANT WAY
EXEMPTING PROPERTY TAXES FOR
MISSING THEIR PRODUCTION FOR
EXAMPLE SO AGAIN --
THIS IS -- I
THINK THERE SHOULD BE A PLACE
HOLDER OF MONEY FOR THIS BUT
EXACTLY HOW YOU DO IT WHAT THAT
LEVEL IS COMPARED TO OTHER NEEDS
AS ONE AND I THINK WE SHOULD
TALK ABOUT.
TERMS WILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
I'D I THINK GO WE NEED TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE GOAL IS HERE
AND IF IF THE GOAL IS TO DO
SOMETHING SUBSTANTIVE ARE WE
REALLY MOVING THE DIAL.
BY -- JUST
TAKE A YOU KNOW ONE TIME LUMP
SUM OF A HALF BILLION DOLLARS --
WHICH AT THE COST OF PRODUCTION
OF MOST HOUSING TODAY ACROSS THE
STATE.
BEING SOMEWHERE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER UNIT --
PRODUCES A THOUSAND UNITS TIME
NOT SAYING THAT THOSE THOUSAND
UNITS ARE NOT IMPORTANT FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD BE ABLE TO
LIVE AND BUT THE NEED.
THAT NUMBER OF UNITS --
I JUST THINK WE NEED TO THINK
MORE COMPREHENSIVELY ABOUT THIS --
THIS POINT THAT I'M MAKING
APPLIES TO MANY OF THE OTHER
THINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT TODAY.
IF WE DON'T FIND WAYS TO CREATE
HOUSING THAT GO ABOVE AND BEYOND --
OF THIS KIND OF SUBSIDY --
OR FIND WAYS TO LOWER THE PER
UNIT CONSTRUCTION COST.
I JUST DON'T SEE HOW WE CATCH UP
WITH THE NEED.
I OPEN THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
SAYS THE MAN NOT LIKE HAS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA --
JUST WANTED.
TO SAY THAT WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE --
OF EXPANDING THIS TO HIGHER
INCOME LEVELS AS DEPENDING ON
WHERE OUR HABITAT AFFILIATES ARE
LOCATED WE DO SERVE --
INDIVIDUALS OUT TO HIGHER LEVELS
OF THE EMI AND SO WE'RE WE'RE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS --
PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
LOUIS FRONT THEIR BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIAN BE --
MANY OF THE ACTIVISTS AROUND THE
STATE ARE ON THINGS LIKE SSI
ABOUT MOST MEMBERS OF OUR
MOVEMENT ARE ARE REASONABLY
MIDDLE CLASS --
WE PRETTY STRONGLY FEEL THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD RESOURCES ON
THOSE WITH THE DEEPEST NEED FOR
HOUSING --
CAM ALIGNING OUR COMMENTS
SIMILAR TO TO THE DOES
PREVENTION BY --
THE LA --
OTHER PROPOSALS CAN REALLY HELP
THE STATE --
ELIMINATE BARRIERS TO MISSING
MIDDLE HOUSING PROPOSALS LIKE
ASSEMBLY BILL --
SIXTY EIGHT WHICH WOULD INCREASE
THE NUMBER EIGHTY USING
CALIFORNIA FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TANG OR SB FIFTY FROM CENTER
WINNER --
THOSE PROPOSALS ARE MUCH MORE
STRATEGICALLY TARGETED AT
GETTING THIS TYPE OF HOUSING
THAT WE NEED --
WHILE OTHER PROGRAMS LIKE OUR
SHELTER PROGRAMS AND ARE LIKE
THAT PROGRAMS THE PROGRAMS WERE
ALL DISCUSSING TODAY --
REMAIN UNDONE UNDERFUNDED THANKS
THANK YOU.
WHICH IS TO OUR LAST AUTUMN
ISSUE NUMBER SIX A REMOVAL OF
REMOVAL OF THE 55%.
VOTER PROUVER THRESHOLD FOR
ENHANCED INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICTS.
THE ISSUANCE AND PAIRING WITH
OPPORTUNITIES --
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
REMOVING THE 55% VOTER APPROVAL
REQUIRED BEFORE ENHANCED
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS CAN ISSUE LONG TERM
DEBT.
THE SHOULD MAKE IT EASIER FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO USE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING TOOL
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE TRAILER BILL.
OIL.
OUR WE WOULD JUST NOTE AS
REFLECTED IN THE AGENDA THAT THE
LEGISLATURE TO MOVE FORWARD THIS
PROPOSAL THERE SOME CONSTANT
EXCUSE ME THERE'D BE SOME
CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTIONS
POTENTIALLY THAT WOULD NEED TO
BE ADDRESSED [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY.
MEET US.
WE ARE YOU KNOW.
GET ENOUGH --
SO I'M GONNA GO HOME AND JUST
MAKE A STATEMENT SO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE HELD A
SPECIAL HEARING LESTER LOOKING
SPECIFICALLY AT THE ISSUE OPPOSE
READER REDEVELOPMENT FINANCING
TOOLS.
WHAT WE HEARD WAS THAT THESE NEW
TOOLS ARE NOT BEING USED?
BUT BECAUSE THEY LACKED BUT
BECAUSE THEY LACK OF FLEXIBILITY
ARE TOO HARD TO FORM LIKE.
YEAH I F. DIS CAN REALLY ONLY BE
USED AS A ONE LAYER MULTI
LAYERED FINANCING PLANS ARE
COBBLED TOGETHER TO FUND
PROJECTS WE NEED TO GIVE LOCAL
AGENCIES ADDITIONAL TOOLS NOT
JUST THE ABILITY TO CAPTURE
THEIR OWN TAX.
INCREMENT WE TALK ABOUT
COMMUNITIES NOT MOVING FORWARD
AGGRESSIVELY ENOUGH TO FINANCE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE.
YET WE IS A STATE MAINTAIN
RIDICULOUS BEARS LIKE TWO THIRDS
VOTE FOR INVESTMENTS OF BONTA
SPECIAL TAXES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
I HOPE THE ADMINISTRATION AS
PART OF THIS CA ONE AS A
CRITICAL PIECE OF THIS PUZZLE AS
BE PARTNERS IN SOLVING.
THANK YOU. FOR VOEPEL.
WHEN I WAS MAYOR OF MY CITY WE
HAD THESE --
ZONES.
AND I FELT VERY COMFORTABLE.
WHEN THE PEOPLE?
VOTED TO TAX THEMSELVES AT 55%
VOTER APPROVAL LEVELS --
I BY LOOK UPON.
THIS AS BEING A USEFUL TOOL. FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT ALSO IT
TRAMPLES UPON PEOPLE'S RIGHT TO
TAX THEMSELVES BEHIND A FREE
VOTE.
SO -- I'M
NOT LOOKING AT THIS REAL
POSITIVELY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
RESEARCHER.
I FIRST WANT TO THANK A THE
CHAIR LOCAL GOVERNMENT FOR HER
PROPOSAL ONE THAT I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AND I DO THINK.
IT'S AN IDEA THAT'S TIME IS
COMPETENTLY WITH THE CRISIS WERE
AND I WANT TO TALK FOR A MOMENT
ABOUT --
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING --
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAD
PROPOSED UP FOCUSING ON E. I. F.
DISS THANK YOU PROBABLY KNOW --
THERE ARE MANY OF US WHO BELIEVE
THAT WE NEED TO BRING BACK SOME
VERSION OF REDEVELOPMENT --
WE HAVE AB ELEVEN WHICH I KNOW
THE AUTHORED BY MANY MEMBERS
HEREMISTER GLORIA --
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY MISTER BLOOM
MISTER GLORIA MR TANG MS WICKS
MYSELF AND OTHERS.
ON THE QUESTION I HAVE IS THE
BUDGET DOESN'T.
INCLUDE A GENERAL FUND ON GOING --
IT FOR SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR TAX
INCREMENT FINANCING I'M
WONDERING IF THE GOVERNOR DOES
SUPPORT USING THE I'VE D. E. I.
F. T. IS OR SOME OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING TOOL --
WILL THE ADMINISTRATION BE
MAKING A COMMITMENT AROUND
GENERAL FOR A GENERAL FUND USES
FOR THOSE DOLLARS.
AT THIS TIME I DON'T THINK I'M
ABLE TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION I
CAN GET BACK TO YOU ON A WITH
SOMETHING I'M NOT GREAT LOOK FOR
TO THAT CONVERSATION THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS THE
COMMITTEE.
GOING OPEN UP PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY I WILL CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT
SO.
A LOT TO DIGEST TODAY FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE --
FOR FINANCE --
A LOT OF UNKNOWNS I'M SURE WILL
BE FIGURING OUT SHORTLY AND THE
FOR TO GETTING INFORMATION AND
THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING US
TODAY.
THIS CONCLUDES OUR HEARING BUT
WILL BE BACK NEXT WEEK